earlier this morning Steven Crowder on
his program louder with Crowder released
portions of the Nashville trans
Manifesto it has now been confirmed by
local news the police are Furious and
they're launching an investigation into
how these images leaked now the
presumption is it is not the full
Manifesto we don't know for sure we
don't know how much was in this but uh
it looks like the individual ual in
question was motivated by anti-white
hatred as well as just generally being
unwell but the hatred of white people
seem to be a strong motivating factor
from the information that we have so far
so we're going to talk about that plus
we got a bunch of other uh other really
big news Trump testified today and he uh
he apparently roasted the judge and the
prosecutor or I should say the uh the
attorney for New York calling them uh
frauds or insinuate that may have been
his lawyer actually but uh basically
breaking down all of his legitimate
business practices they're they're
definitely trying to run him over the C
this we'll talk about that plus a new
poll has come out the New York Times is
basically saying that if the election is
held today Donald Trump wins handily he
is ahead in five of six swing states
needed to win now just a warning to
everybody that doesn't mean you can sit
around and do nothing because they want
to lull you into a false sense of
security you better go out and vote so
we'll talk about that before we get
started my friends head over to cast
brew.com to get the best cup of coffee
of ever had pick up our Halloween
special edition rise robberto Jr it is
limited once it is gone it will never
exist again so if you want this fancy
art of a chicken leg bursting from the
ground like a zombie as we make fun of
our dead mascot then uh pick it up today
but also you can get everyone's favorite
Appalachian nights and rise with
robberto JR when you buy coffee from
casper.com you're supporting the show
and you're supporting our efforts to
build coffee shops all over the place
where y'all can hang out and physical
reality and make friends and build
community and that's kind of the plan so
our first location is uh is getting
there it's getting there up in
Martinsburg West Virginia you don't want
to miss out it's going to be a lot of
fun also go to timcast.net
because you're the only guy doing three
posts a day with updates on the news and
that's how I got into you so honored to
be here I work for Infowars I'm
currently hosting a show in the mornings
until Owen Shroyer is back from prison
and I create a AI generated content for
them right on well thanks for hanging
out we also got Hannah clir hey I'm
Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net
jacket uh with a pin from Tom Ellsworth
from value tainment what's up Tom I know
you're out there listening I love you
man thank you for the pin Serge and I'm
surge.com uh yeah let's get into it
here's the big news this is the first
story it's the biggest story of the day
it's dominated the headlines Nashville
school shooter Audrey Hal's Manifesto
leaked trans murderer vowed to kill
privileged white kids at Covenant School
Steven Crowder leaked photos of the
manifesto on Twitter and his podcast
Nashville PD has refused to release the
information despite media requests hail
28 shot and killed six people including
three young kids I believe they were all
under the age of nine on March 23rd she
was shot dead by police within 14
minutes of launching the tech now the
big story with this uh release is
information about the motivations it
would seem that from what we have so far
the motivation was anti-white hatred
there are some reports that the full
Manifesto the full notebook is actually
it actually contains way more and some
people are saying actually the full
thing shows this individual hated
everybody but if that were true they
would need to release this to the public
now I don't know that's going to happen
but perhaps for whatever reason this got
leaked it was to try and force the
release of the rest of it which I kind
of don't know if that makes sense
because whoever leaked it could have
just leaked the rest we don't know
exactly why only these select Pages were
released and I got to be honest I'm also
not convinced there is any more that may
be an excuse where someone's trying to
downplay what this individual uh uh had
actually been motivated by we have this
from the post-millennial local media
Outlet confirms Nashville trans School
shooters anti-white Manifesto pages are
authentic and then we have of course an
investigation is currently underway
after release of alleged Covenant
Shooters writings Nashville mayor says
so it's confirmed now I believe we have
multiple reporters confirming this that
uh the individual was motivated by
anti-white hatred and now all of a
sudden we're starting to see these
videos pop up people are basically and
they've been do this for a while but
they're pulling up they're B they're
making montages of all of the insane
college professor and university
university rhetoric around violence
targeting white people and there was one
that I saw on Twitter that's so shocking
and insane it's no wonder people are
being radicalized by this people are
also calling out Joe Biden who has made
numerous speeches about the problems and
dangers of white supremacy now you can
you can certainly argue that people are
allowed to criticize and condemn white
supremacy of course they are but when
these universities and media Outlets
claim that Simply Having a family is
white supremacy you can see how this
starts the rhetoric starts getting crazy
now I guess the questions are was the
FBI and the and and the police
withholding this intentionally because
of what it contained or is is something
else going on yeah it's hard to say I
mean there's a line in particular from
from the one of the photograph pages
that says you know i' I've been wanting
to do this for a long time I'm excited
uh I almost got caught I believe it's
they say the summer of 2021 and so we we
have to wonder who why why does this
person feel that way there was reporting
that Audrey hail had been uh you know
under her parents care to a certain
level that there were emotional and
psychological isses was already known to
at least her family um but this to me
implies something bigger than just you
know people were concerned about my
behavior which implies that there's more
to the writings than just the three
pages I mean if she's been planning this
thing for a couple years or had issues
for a couple years and she wrote about
how excited for the past two weeks that
she's been right so I bet she was
writing every day for the two weeks
doing her sort and and there's a there
there's also report there may be a
14-minute video yeah I wouldn't be
surprised I mean Audrey Hale also
reached out to people right before I'm
sorry 10-minute video I got wrong uh you
know if
I I approve um it's okay I I forgive
your four minute laps no the thing is if
there had been a
um I wouldn't be surprised if there's a
video I mean especially with younger
Millennial attackers they're more versed
in social media now than ever and so it
makes sense that that would be the case
I know Audrey Hill was contacting people
through Instagram right before going
into the school I mean this person was
um reaching out and also being extremely
destructive to their fellow human beings
one of the pages if if I'm remembering
correctly was dated I think February of
2023 and so we know that this you know
Manifesto diary whatever you want to
call it has been documenting a
developing uh motivational pattern I I
don't think this would with this was
withheld because it was implicating the
left in their radical
rhetoric I think when you look at this
you see two things as you mentioned the
the the shooter said I almost got caught
mhm also says I'm going to be checking
security what does this tell
us the police state the centralized
policing Authority will not be there to
protect you from these circumstances and
in fact there was a actually this was
posted on Twitter in a community notes
there's a study done in 2022 that found
34.4% of mass shootings were stopped by
a person who is legally armed and when
you remove gunfree zones from that
metric it increases to 51% of mass
shooting stopped by individuals who are
legally armed and I think the problem
here is with this Manifesto what you see
is I think we got to be careful about
the anti-white propaganda angle to this
which is important I'm not saying it's
not we should definitely call out the
the weird creepy racist leftist whatever
but also consider this is hugely
damaging to The Narrative of gun-free
zones to local politicians if the
narrative came out that gun-free zones
and and this is true everyone knows this
that gun free zones are creating risk
but it was like the headline story
Manifesto reveals lack of security
gunfree zones and lack of FBI Integrity
resulted in this happening you're going
to have people going to their
politicians be like why did you do this
so when you look at how the FBI has you
know what's what's the famous what's the
what's the meme now was known to the FBI
they say you know it's the they do the
BART meme where it's like say the line
Bart and he's like the shooter was known
to the
FBI every time there's always an
opportunity but what happens is you get
gun control activists coming out saying
aha we must blame the guns which is a
complete distraction I don't think it is
always about gun control I think it is
about uhoh people are going to get mad
at us because we're the ones who who
created this system and made it this way
right now what you've got happening is
Democrats arguing that we should have
politicians do a thing when in reality
it's de it's it's politicians mainly
Democrats doing the thing which resulted
in the crisis in the first place and
they don't want anyone to realize that
yeah I I think that's right I think the
other aspect that's jumped out of me was
that there's uh a very serious anti-
elitist uh messaging throughout this
there's a specific line where Hill WR
you know those kids are awful at their
private school with their parents
expensive cars or whatever it is you
know and from what I know rep reporting
I saw from local Outlets said that hail
had attended this school and so this
behavior is bizarre in a lot of fronts
and I think now it's just a rush to spin
it as fast as possible uh I think that's
why the anti-gun narrative is going to
be so easily introduced here but it's
also important to acknowledge that this
person was deeply psychologically
Disturbed and if people knew this FBI
local law enforcement whatever they
failed the community around them it's
weird to me that the manifesto hadn't
been digitized by the perpetrator
because so often when we see events like
this part of the motive is to get it out
as fast as possible but obviously it
never been digitized because there's
spelling errors and stuff in it I mean
this is something that was like not on
the internet at all I don't think and
was just written for personal use so I
wonder what H was thinking to seeking to
accomplish by writing this down well
I'll tell you what the scary thing I
think is uh when we talk about civil
conflict in the United States I often
mention that I view the right as what I
would call like the acute threat whereas
the left is the blunt or obtuse threat
The Chronic threat you could say well
it's not so muchas Works acute and
chronic it's it's not it's not chronic
it is blunt
versus pointed and sharp piercing versus
bludgeoning right um acute meaning it's
EXT and it hits you hard whereas blunt
is it you know the left you get hundreds
of thousands of far-left extremists they
go around punching and threatening
people none of these rise to a national
Level news story but it's happening all
the time to the point where you're
getting shoplifting you're getting
you're getting these protesting
occupations and they bubble up sometimes
and and make the news but it's never the
most shocking story with the right you
get some deranged Lun going into a
church I shouldn't say the right but
what they what they would say is a the
right what I should say is anti-left or
um anti-government whatever you want to
call it and then as for the for the left
I think we're speaking in in in
generalities we should probably I I I
don't know if the the simplification of
left and right is is helping for anybody
because this person's clearly not a
leftist you know what I mean they're not
they're not a communist necess well they
probably are deeply influenced by it but
anyway my point is this what what what
is typically stated by the by the right
by the media as the right it's like
rarely and it and one guy a lone wolf
does some crazy thing killing a lot of
people makes International headlines and
everyone says we must stop the right
they're so dangerous and it's bad it's
seriously bad it does need to be stopped
however we can on the left you have the
Chaz chop protest you have the
autonomous Zone in Minneapolis you have
the Summer of Love protests you have the
529 Insurrection all of these things
result in severe injuries and sometimes
death but what ends up happening in the
summer of love you have mass rights
across the entire country 30 people die
but you don't have one person killing 30
people right so the media doesn't treat
the story like a mass death incident
even though it was and because of that
so what scary to me is what we're now
seeing is more left ideologically
aligned individuals engaging in what I
would describe as acute terror act and
and and violence and extremism and when
you combine the so when you take a a
left ideological bent like this ramp the
extremism up to 11 combine it with the
fact that there's hundreds of thousands
of PE of these people and they have
already engaged in Mass death incidents
it's like that's starting to get much
much scarier the right the right doesn't
protest they they barely ever go out you
don't see a lot of left left Wingers
walking around with ARs or assault
assault weapons so much I mean now you
do at some of these protests but this is
sort of like a new development in in in
in uh Seattle over the past uh probably
seven years leftists like the John Brown
gun club and the Red Guard or whatever
they call themselves they March around
with AR15s and they've even been
pointing them at vehicles and
controlling traffic saw that happened in
awesome with that guy that went to
prison for defending himself when it
happened to him and so what we're
starting to see over the past few years
is the left has this ubiquitous fervor
where they go out and smash things and
Destroy things and now they're adding to
their to their uh to their ranks serious
violent extremists who are engaging in I
mean this was earlier earlier in the
year and the right still doesn't have on
average any of the lowlevel terror
doesn't even have that much high level
Terror I think the reality is what what
is described as the right probably is
just regular people and what it's
described as the left is an activist
base it's also this person Audrey hail
was like on some sort of pharmaceutical
is this confirmed I mean a lot of these
Mass Shooters are on some sort of SSRI
or or
pharmaceutical I read the story but I
think that there was there was a
therapist at one point wasn't there I
can't remember I don't know for sure but
I think it's a a logical assumption
especially because SSR are widely
prescribed what deadly or an AR15 or an
SSR it's well that's not a real there's
no real is migher than the sword they
say that that's been quoted over long
you know the pill is mightier than the
gun warp the mind and then the the
depends on uh I would I I you know you
could theoretically argue that it is
unfair to call an AR15 deadly in any
respect right well I would say that a
gun is more is more likely to help you
commit suicide and then Sr SSR is more
likely to help you kill a bunch of
people before you commit suicide well so
the issue is ssris could result in
complete generational collapse if you
have mind altering jug drugs being
mass-produced and mass prescribed it
could actually destroy the fabric of of
a Nation whereas a rifle which is a
which is a a a weapon it's it's an
object intended to to be destructive
could actually help protect and defend a
nation or destroy a nation so it's
actually kind of neutral in that regard
uh either way you can say it's deadly
that's the intent of it but if the goal
of the AR is to uh actually stabilize
that is to say uh uh what do they say an
armed Society it's a polite M you may
actually have weapons but everyone's
like you must respect other people
because they're armed and you don't want
to start a fight and that actually
simmers things down whereas mind
altering drugs can actually just make
everything go nuclear you know within a
few years yeah especially because you
don't know how people will react to them
I mean some people can take ssris for a
long time and see minimal side effects
other people uh become more unstable
because of them it's impossible to say
and that's the gamble we take in a
phological dependent Society all the
unstable people are likely to be more
like to be prescrib them too so your
nuts before you get on it and then
there's this correlation that isn't
causation exactly I think that's a
really good point actually a lot of
people are like aha this person was on
medication yeah maybe they were trying
to stop them like maybe they were like
hey maybe this is you know that's the
thing we I mean it's very very hard to
tell how people react medications it's
not that there's never a case for them
some people legitimately need them it's
just it's a trial and error they just
give you pills and see if it works and
if they don't we try and adjust I mean
that's unfortunately how this works I
think it's actually a really good point
the argument that aha the person was on
SSRI it's the it's the medication is
similar to the liberal argument where
they're like aha they had a gun it's the
gun right and there are a lot of people
I think there's probably tens of was
vaccinated and boosted right yeah
exactly you could you can isolate
anything figured it out now probably
probably a fair point to say there are a
lot of people who are taking ssris who
are not doing this you know I hope of
course there are I mean they're so
widely prescribed and we don't have like
this doesn't happen all the time I mean
this is tragic and part of what's what's
shocking about this is because it's it's
so unusual right she's she's a female
killer perhaps she doesn't think of
herself that way uh but a female killer
who attacks somewhere that they have
ties too I mean this is unusual for both
wh for female attackers and for school
shootings I feel like there's more of an
anonymous component a lot of times when
you get Mass Shooters like some sort of
endocrine disruption or something or
just generally like this is someone who
is behaving in a way that we don't see I
mean statistically Mass Shooters are
male and I guess I depends on how you
classify this person I focuses the
conversation to the dangers of racial
Supremacy and not white supremacy or
black Supremacy or Jewish Supremacy or
Islamic like Arab suprem it's about
racial Supremacy and how horrible it is
to think of that and to focus on that
and to live in that state of mind where
you think One race is trying to be
superior over like just don't don't be a
racist you can actually extrapolate that
further and just say the real issue is
any ideology that would propose
extremist solutions to their perceived
problems
and so for this individual how you
define extremist though I mean someone
willing to kill a bunch of people to
impose their political will that makes
sense now to be fair people but they
throw it around a lot like if you're
abortion you're extremist you know I can
already hear the leftist going oh so
what you're saying the US government's
extremists yes yes I
am yeah when when they're when they're
blowing up kids overseas to enact their
goals and the American people
overwhelmingly say no every single time
they're asked and consistently vote for
the politician who's like no war that
being said Nikki Haley seems to be doing
well in the polls to a certain degree
but most Americans the overwhelming
majority are like hey we don't want to
waste money on war so yes there are
extremists in our government willing to
kill people to get what they want but
let's jump to this story this next story
we have a tweet from Steven Crowder
Facebook is now censoring the Nashville
Manifesto this is what we saw almost
immediately after the story broke this
is what the news uh uh this is what big
tech companies do many news media
Outlets they didn't want to cover the
story social media companies don't want
to uh uh get into any kind of debate and
this is a serious problem we now know
based on local reporting and statements
from from local politicians the leaks
from Steven Crowder are real and at the
time Facebook was taking them down
Google had their stupid alert when you
searched for it saying the results are
changing rapidly here are some other
stories instead which is what they do
and they don't want you to read these
stories here's what happens big tech
companies basically say if it doesn't
come from the New York Times we will not
allow it if however you get 5,000 local
Outlets reporting it then there's
nothing they can do to stop it but they
tried to stop it MH and so fortunately I
guess local new outs immediately jumped
on the story broke through and the story
made it out I think one of the biggest
fears that Facebook and YouTube and uh
uh many of these other platforms not
Rumble not X for instance Their Fear
Steven Crowder just set the news cycle
right and and the New York Times is
going to try to avoid it they're going
to be like no no no no don't pick up his
story we're the ones who decide what
people are talking about but they've
been losing that position Steven Crowder
uh uh was questioned by these news how
do you know it's real and we stand by
reporting and it is a political comedian
on Youtube who broke the biggest story
today because of people in their Network
I mean from what I understood from what
he was saying during his live stream it
was someone involved in mug Club who was
like I have a contact I know where to
get this and they were able to verify
through that that's pretty impressive
right I mean this ISP all journalists
rely on their readers for tips this is
super normal but it is interesting that
he has built such a relationship that
someone would be willing to potentially
take and I don't know where who the
source was like a professional risk to
get them this information that that
shows a lot of confidence in stepen
Crowder it's citizen journalism that is
not citizen journalism well but the
citizen apply gave the the journalism to
Crowder to amplify the message that's an
aspect of like that's citizen journalism
so this is I I I the idea that this is
citizen journalism was created to
discredit people like Steven Crowder I
know this because I was I was I was at
these conventions I was at these
conferences and I was speaking at these
events and they kept saying you're just
a citizen journalist I said no citizen
journalism is a guy walking his dog and
then all of a sudden he sees a plane in
the sky on fire so he pulls out his
phone and films and it crashes and he
goes whoa and then he tweets a video I
guess there's no way to know who it was
that that delivered didn't give it to
Fox but this but but that's meaningless
the New York Times has sources all day
every day someone in law enforcement
releasing information the New York Times
publishes it Steven Crowder is no
different from the New York Times
granted he is a comedian on YouTube but
his news apparatus that got this
information and published it is the same
as Wikileaks uh uh system the same as
New York times' System you have someone
who liases with a source The Source
provides information the information is
vetted and then
reported I just think it's cool that
this is something he has built right
when he was posting videos initially on
YouTube I'm sure he did not expect to be
in the position he is today which is
that he dis decided what the news was
going to be out I mean he came out with
this on a Monday for a reason this is
going to lead the news cycle at least
for the next couple days probably
through the end of the week it and it
this may actually Force the release of
the full full Manifesto which is
probably the only way we would have
gotten it out so the one of the ideas
that's being put out on on on X on
social media is that these are select
pages and that in reality while
everyone's highlighting the anti-white
sentiment that seems to have motivated
the shooter there's way more in there
and this person hates everybody and uses
slurs for everybody but the selective
page The Selective
release right would would make it seem
like it was
one-sided yeah I mean I think that's
reasonable I I wouldn't be surprised if
it's you know not that I want to make
predictions about such a dark document
but I wouldn't be surprised if there's a
consistent anti-white theme because I
think as far as I can tell Audrey Hill
was white and I think a lot of people
who are raised in uh or who are coming
up in Progressive spheres are trained to
hate themselves especially if they're
well if you look at what was said in it
the the the perpetrator says things like
private schools and fancy khakis and she
attended that school it was very Marxist
esque it was very oppressor versus
oppressed she was taking this back to
the oppressors and she was going to get
the justice and she hoped she had a high
kill count she said things like that in
the document and that's where the mark
like I I posted about something critical
about public schools the other day about
how they're teaching Marxism to our kids
and somebody commented and said they
don't teach Marxism at Public Schools
I'm like you don't explicitly have to
give out a book by Marx to be teaching
Marxism it's this idea of this oppressor
versus this oppressed thing this
critical theory thing and when you just
Ram that down people's heads you end up
like militarizing and radicalizing an
entire generation yeah they indoctrinate
people with Marxism they don't
unfortunately as far as I know actually
teach the theories of Marxism enough
they should probably teach that more so
that you can realize if you were being
indoctrinated no no teaching public if
they taught actual Marxist theory along
with history of Marxism the children
would be crying by the end of the day
and say why would anyone ever do such a
thing those poor people the 100 100
million who are 1958 1962 Great Leap
Forward 100 million it's so easy to be
we're all in this together let's go all
of us and then once the revolution
happens it's between 1958 and 1962 than
white supremacism did between 1619 and
2019 yeah how many people did it in from
four years estimates of 100 million
during the Great during the Great Lea
for in China they starved no I don't
think it was 100 million in four years
those are the high estimates 100 million
yes 1958 1962 look up the Great Leap
Forward on Wikipedia I believe estimates
go as high as 100 million there are
lower ones that are in like the 50 60
range room is filled with rapid typing
30 30 and 45 30 and 45 yeah 100 is the
total deaths of Communism I'm pretty
sure yeah I don't know you got to grab
the mic brother yeah yeah I know give it
to me Serge what's the word we can't no
we can't hear you no one else can either
yeah yeah there in the 100 million is
over the entire period of Comm of
communist China not necessarily from
like it's not no that's all communism oh
okay I believe that there is a study
that estimates that 100 million Chinese
died specifically from the Great lead
forward but it might not be the most
widely accepted study but I'm almost
positive that on the Wikipedia page for
the great Le forward the Wikipedia says
55 is the highend and 15 is it is
Wikipedia we do have take gra or so but
I believe you I mean I think this is one
of those things where why would they
well it's not that bad if it's only 50
million jeez 50 million people no I
think way more than the Holocaust it's
like 10 times more and this is like the
greatly forward I mean I can try and
explain it it's when he took like a
bunch of of the the teachers and things
and then he sent them out to the farms
and was like we got to yeah he wanted no
the other way around he wanted to
industrialize the the nation of China to
make it a factory based sort of exporter
and so he took all the agricultural
people and put them in the cities so
nobody was working the farms and
everybody that was in responsible for
the districts of the Farms was too
scared to report to their higher ups
they weren't meeting quotas on harvest
because China's you know communism
you're scared to tell your boss you're
not meeting numbers and so they didn't
realize that there was like a mass
shortage of food until it was too late
and everybody starved over like four
years that's why I I always feel like
you can't trust any numbers that come
out of China because number one why
would they report anything accurately to
the outside world anyways and also why
would they internally report accurately
there's no there's no benefit for them
you know but why would the US yeah I
tweeted this out over the weekend Tik
Tock may be Chinese Communist propaganda
but Facebook and YouTube are American
Communist prop that was what the fourth
all about shout out to Elon Musk
liberating X and to Chris pavlovski for
making Rumble and for lifting up the
fourth pillar that's what these guys are
doing it's supposed to be a fourth
branch government it's not really but
it's the fourth estate it's journalism
it's the journalists that keep the
politicians to task that cover the
government and make sure it's honest and
that unfortunately the fascism involved
with the digitalization of our news
media has been way too easy for the
government to corrupt so I'm I'm happy
to see organizations like mines Rumble
and X holding the truth like like uh
Rumble they tweeted out on X we're
holding the line about Crowder post
they're not going to block it like this
like this Facebook did yeah shout out it
all started with Cambridge analytica
after they blamed the election of Donald
Trump in 2016 on social media all of a
sudden all of the big tech companies got
really scared and really ramped up their
censorship because I think that there
was this either explicit or like
unstated threat they felt like the
government was going to come in and
split them up if they didn't do
something what was the Cambridge Scandal
I don't I don't think it was that you
don't think so I think it was that they
were just once again trying to
manipulate and control the system for
sure yeah so Cambridge analytica had
access to what was it like 40 million
data that was allegedly used to win the
election for Trump and it's and I think
it's complete nonsense the idea was that
this company Cambridge analytica and uh
group had access to user data which they
use to Target voters and the reason why
you know that's stupid and nonsensical
is that uh we've talked to Dr Robert
Epstein who's pointed out that Google I
I love this we can simplify the
algorithm manipulation electoral
argument with a very very simple
statement Facebook sends reminders to
Democrat on Election Day and not to
Republicans that's the only thing they
need to do to steal an election do they
still do that so according to Dr Epstein
who appeared on the culture war two
weeks ago when they were tracking their
user their like 10,000 plus user group
for uh studying their their social media
experiences they found that 59% of
Republicans received a reminder but 100%
of Democrats received a reminder oh that
sounds like that should be illegal yes
and when in kind abely and when Ted Cruz
wrote a letter saying what you are doing
you know we have questions about this he
said they saw instantly Google turned
the bias system off in Georgia so that
means that the implication is Google is
intentionally manipulating
elections oh man I made a video in 2007
I was like vote Barack Obama you're
going to win the election vote for
Barack Obama everyone Barack you're the
next president and I was like manip I
felt like I was manipulating the
election I mean in a way I was like it's
your fault man Google they actually
featured that video and put it on the
front page of the news and politics
section talk about interfering like it
not it was not illegal but it was just
Mass manipulation of vote for my guy
right when they when they pushed your
video well probably because there's not
an equal representation right it's it's
whoever is willing to support Obama can
be on the front page but anyone else
does not get to be on the trending page
does not get to exist at all it was
total political bias both me and the guy
that featured me wanted Obama to win so
I feel like yours isn't manipulative
like if you really feel like they should
vote for Obama you have a platform you
can say that right it's different when
YouTube decides certain videos get to
make it to the front page certain videos
get to be boosted by the algorithm and
it's not equally applied right I mean we
know this through our own experiences I
mean you're on YouTube there are certain
videos that you know are performing well
that do not make it to the pages or list
that they should because YouTube is
intentionally diverting them elsewhere
it's not always in the best interest of
the business either like when they
censor people like Alex Jones from
YouTube that was we're talking like
hundreds of millions of views
consistently
and so it seems to me like almost a
betrayal of the shareholders of the
company when you're bringing people off
the platform just for political motives
I wonder if there's a lawsuit Avenue
there because there's a duty to do to
honor what you what's in the best
interest of the shareholder so the fact
that there's a political motivation that
seems to transcend the monetary
motivation seems to me to imply that
there's this Twitter files thing going
on but with all these other platforms
where there's just intelligence
Community operatives just kind of but we
do know that uh Nancy Pelosi is net
worth her and her husband is around $200
million so uh the political is monetary
yeah the political motivation uh and and
let me just say what a strange and
unfortunate coincidence that the uh
Clinton Global initiative or the Clinton
Foundation I believe their uh their
contributions dried up shortly after
Hillary Clinton lost the election just
what a they just restarted it too didn't
they the Clinton foundation for to
rebuild Ukraine that's what they said so
the general idea is this the idea was
that the expectation with Hillary
becoming president everybody's donating
money to her foundation which is a
laundering I guess and then the idea is
if she becomes president then those
favors get paid back they purchased
something but she lost and this what I
really really love I just want to shout
out the 2016 was you know the that
election oh boy I remember that night oh
so well all the Trump all the all the
Trump supporter well I'm sorry I was at
the Sputnik office with Cassandra
Fairbanks and um Cassandra McDonald
sorry and uh she was the only Trump
supporter there everyone else was upset
people were crying and she was laughing
crying and it was
but what was really funny about it was
that the establishment machine of money
churn and and revolving doors was just
shattered in an instant and the Panic
was absolutely hilarious for the DC
Elites who owed millions of dollars to
foreign donors and lobbyists that they
weren't going to be able to to uh pay
back now you have Matt Gates doing the
same thing to Kevin McCarthy and all of
that money put into him becoming speaker
was just ripped away from him and he
ain't going to be able to pay it back I
just love watching the machine get
ripped to shreds yeah anyway
purpose of the United States oh sorry
mean that this this whole United States
Revolution away from the the machine of
the British Empire I mean the whole
point is ripping that thing to shreds
and creating a new system that's way
better American republicanism that's the
whole the whole ethos of the United
States was to rip the machine to shreds
that machine that was stomping on the
neck of George Washington and his
buddies so we do have another massive
breaking story in fact it is so breaking
it is a Twitter thread that has not yet
been written up but this is the
censorship Industrial complex report
being released by The GOP rep Jim Jordan
says bomb shall report hundreds of
secret reports show how DHS cisa the gec
state department in Stanford and others
worked together to censor Americans
before the 2020 election including true
information jokes and opinions the
federal government disinformation
experts at universities big Tech and
others and others work together through
the election Integrity partnership to
Monitor and censor American speech let
me just pause right there I'll give you
a personal example that election in
Integrity project or whatever it's
called claimed that I Tim pool was one
of the largest spreaders super spreaders
of election misinformation you're a
super spreader now here's the thing that
actually was shocking to me because I
have since the election maintained Trump
lost to Joe Biden MH often saying that
the issue was ballot harvesting and
things that they they put out the Time
magazine article so why would they claim
I was spreading misinformation when
you've got it's because they want to
attack influence right and so long as I
was reporting on say Texas Pennsylvania
or instances that needed to be
adjudicated it wasn't that I was
spreading misinformation all of my
sources News Guard certified it was that
they could not allow there to be a
narrative that there were questions that
needed to be answered by courts so they
lie claim I spread misinformation don't
say what misinformation that is
therefore it makes it impossible to sue
them and when the media reports it you
can't sue the media for for reporting
what a university said but let's read
more Jim Jordan says according to one EI
I member it was created at the request
of sisa the head of the EIP also stated
that EIP was was created after working
on some monitoring ideas with sisa EIP
stakeholders including the federal
government would submit misinformation
reports the EIP would analyze the report
and find similar content across
platforms it would then submit the
report to Big Tech often with a
recommendation on how to censor ladies
and gentlemen what we are seeing what we
have long speculated and and gotten
various reports hinting at or confirming
portions of is now the overt and W GOP
government Congressional confirmation
the US government intelligence agencies
were using third parties through
universities to censor people who
supported Donald
Trump yeah and they use the word
stakeholders too which just immediately
makes me think of CLA Schwab who's like
the future isn't stockholders it's
stakeholders with like the whole great
reset narrative is just either
intentionally or accidentally seeping in
even the writing word the US stakeholder
in reference to what the great reset he
like the future the the industrial
fourth Revolution is when he quoted it
he quoted it in then the thread
somewhere where he said the word
stakeholders something like us
stakeholders they targeted politicians
Margy Taylor green Governor Mike Huck on
there yeah uh Candace Owens Jack pesobic
Charlie Kirk Benny Johnson Tom fitt yeah
I'm not on these lists I know you know
they they put it in my Wikipedia page
that I'm a super spreader based on the
EAP and Jim Jordan didn't even give me
an honorable mention come on J we got to
bring him on the show I met got pay for
this no also say uh Michelle Malin Dave
Ruben James O'Keefe it's absolutely
absolutely insane but who isn't on the
list is even more telling right here's
some examples here's one it's a a tweet
from gingr saying Pennsylania Democrats
are method method uh meth meth
methodologically method methodic
methodically why can't I say that word
changing the rules CU I want to say
methodologically but then I keep going
back comp methodically changing the
rules so they can steal an election it
is amazing open toest ruthless
and will I can't read what it says
unless the state is flooded with law
that was before the election too so he's
not even making a false claim about how
the who won the election it's an opinion
it's an opinion
op I mean that's the thing though they
will pick all kinds of people that they
don't want talking at the the same time
here's a joke they removed no no comedy
either you know he said mik H said stood
in the rain for an hour to early vote
today when I got home I filled in my
stack of mailin ballots and then voted
the ballots of my deceased par and
grandparents they vote just like me he's
making a joke that's absolutely amazing
he really did that who did we miss did
you have a social media post that was
targeted by the EIP it's clear why
Stanford tried uh tried only produce
these after the Judiciary GOP and
weaponization threatened contempt um yes
I will absolutely be reaching out to my
Representatives about um how I can
assist for if there is any action being
taken based on the people who are named
uh I absolutely will throw my name in
let's get Jim Jordan on the show
Cassandra make it happen I love that guy
personally and I think this is very
preent absolutely but also what happens
that's my thing like I I think this is
great information to come out and then
and then what that's what I worry about
with all of these we had an
investigation we uncovered this stuff
anyways now that we've told you that's
the end of it well now what you do is
you build censorship resistant systems
protocols things like Noster Noster
however you want to pronounce it um I
was actually did an interview with Bill
opman today CEO and founder of mindes
talking about censorship resistance and
things like that Brier Mesh networking
things things that can't be censor you
can you can always censor them locally
like you can Blacklist them from
appearing on your part of the of the
network but you can't make it go away
well the crazy thing too is is just like
we were talking about earlier a lot of
the stuff that's coming out now is stuff
that was already publicly known like if
you did a little bit of research years
ago you could find details about the
hunter Biden laptop what was on it
there's Biden laptops.com where you can
search based on keyword and find stuff
like the public was able to access the
information that while Joe Biden was
vice president $23.7 million went to
metabiota and Rosemont Senate cartners
was invested in metabiota so those
returns would have gone back to Joe
Biden's pocket and so that information's
always already been public four years
and now we're just seeing these
committees just admit that it's real
admit that the laptop's real admit that
this evidence is real I think that it's
it's just telling how screwed up our
system is when it's not about whether or
not people have access to the truth but
it's about who admits the truth is true
in March of 21 EIP put out a a report
that that a report by uh the guardian
reported on it saying 15 of the top 25
21 offenders were verified including
Eric Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump Jr
James O'Keefe Tim P Elijah Riot and
Sydney Powell all 21 of the top accounts
for misinformation leaned rightwing the
study showed uh I never put out
misinformation and that's why and
everyone knows this all of my sources
always are certified by newsguard I
think news guard is biased I think they
have they they have posted incredibly
wrong information about Tim cast.com
they've they did this dirty trick where
they claimed that they emailed us and
because we didn't respond they
downgraded us again even though we
checked they didn't how are you
rightwing though I don't think of you as
like a right Wier well it's it's lies
but here's my point if I'm going to use
their standard for what's true and they
call me misinformation that's exactly
the point so there was um a really
interesting story pertaining to co and
the lab leak where they wrote I think
they wrote it an our uh uh uh News Guard
wrote it an hour report or someone
else's I could be I can't remember which
one and they said that this is in yeah I
think it was ours they said it is
incorrect the uh it was something about
like Ukraine Labs or something like that
it's not true this was never revealed
and then I showed them the New York Post
in the Daily Mail News Guard certified
sources confirming what they claimed was
false I said now hold on you say this
story about Co lab leak is false false
but you certified Daily Mail and the New
York Post as factual and they claim both
of these that it's true so who do I
trust the random employee telling me I'm
wrong or your own certified news sources
and they were like oops if Stanford is
going to come out and accuse me of
wrongdoing despite that it shows you
that it's political it is fake and they
are simply trying to steal an election
yeah I mean not for have the student
loan crisis but all universities are
basically dependent on federal funding
and so that means that they are
uh they they are an arm of the federal
government to a certain extent they want
to make the federal government happy and
so they'll play ball with them in
whatever way possible I mean the
relationship is obvious and yet we
pretended like this wasn't going to
happen I don't know I don't get
it and me what what did you say about
the student loan crisis that they
they're buying people off by paying me
if you're a college right and you know
that you can charge whatever you want as
long as you make the person take out
student loans which are guaranteed by
the federal government because you can't
declare bankruptcy on them and they will
give them to whoever they think needs
them oh then
youal money under this idea of like oh
we're bringing in students but not to
mention the direct funding that they
just give too so you're ineligible for
your funding as University if you don't
enforce our Title 9 regulations which
don't allow the the defendant to face
his victim if he's accused of sexual
assault on campus and things like that
so you see these kids getting kicked out
of college and stuff for false
accusations of sexual assault it's not
even a criminal court it's just a
College Court that has to do what Title
Nine says otherwise they' not eligible
for federal funding for their for the
University so you see a lot of
atrocities happen on college campuses
related to the fact that they're so
vulnerable and so dependent on the
federal government's funding and I think
we have the same problem at the state
level like we wouldn't see a civil war
from a state unless things got way more
extreme than they even got in 1862 in my
opinion because all the states are so
financially dependent on federal aid for
things like roads and infrastructure
it's like they give us so much money we
would never rebel against them because
all of a sudden that's cut off at a
state level it have to be the people
that would stand up not it's never going
to be a state government you know I have
to wonder with the with this the release
of this report coming from official
government sources that has to Grant
every single one of us standing in a
lawsuit against the government and some
kind of restitution for this I mean they
were attacking our our businesses they
were attacking our character and they
were lying
MH well and especially in this this
business your credibil credibility is
extremely important and for them to say
you're you're super spread of
misinformation based on what nothing
from Stanford University that's a direct
attack on your livelihood uh but again I
stand by as as important as I think this
report is I think it's good even if we
all kind of knew this was happening
anyways to get the truth out there what
are the consequences that anyone
involved in this faces realistically
what can we expect going
forward well the one of the things I was
thinking is that we no longer have
public colleges and make them all
private and not allowed to take
government money hell yeah that's what
I'm talking about we should stop giving
out St loans that makes that's that made
college expensive too all the student
loans like oh there's the customer that
just came to town you can charge
whatever you want also we are Joe Biden
is on the campaign Trail saying I'm
going to forgive student loan debt um or
you could just start giving out stop
giving out student loans right right
this broken system that put hundreds of
millions of Americans into debt we are
just continuing to say we're going to do
even though on the other hand we're
saying we're going to forgive student
loans it doesn't make any sense if the
system is broken stop doing it how
integrated is the student loan what is
it Fanny May Freddy are those the like a
FAFSA application right is that what it
was when you go to col
you're or not they youh as as you're
student you don't have to start pay it
back and if you don't pay it back I
don't think they can arrest you for it
so there's a lot of people that go and
they just never make payments it wrecks
your credit but refuse to pay it back
that's probably why they're just
forgiving it because they know they're
not going to get it any it doesn't
incentivize colleges to actually do
anything to make College affordable
right all the prices went way up the
expectation is that you take out a
student Lo a government-backed loan but
it's not that they accommodate you in
any way I mean that's why it's
interesting to see you know know um like
University Phoenix are online programs
that are saying like we're trying to
give you an option here that is
Affordable because ultimately isn't that
where Shaq went University of Phoenix
got his Doctorate
sh tons of funy O house it's um It's A
system that the federal government
ultimately benefits from because they
say we really we you should go to
college college is so important also
take they were smart though they would
only offer it for targeted Fields they'd
be like all right our competitors is
doing this so we need more Engineers but
how do we incentivize people to be
Engineers oh we give them way more or we
only give money to people who are going
to major in this thing or graduate with
this thing and you're only eligible your
interest rate's way higher if you don't
graduate you know and if you graduate it
goes down there's ways you can
manipulate how you give people money to
give get them to do what you want but
they they're just blanketing it when we
know that there are worker shortages in
certain Fields right it's not an
immediate solution they have to go
through training it'll be four five year
delay on the other hand you would get
qualified people going into it there are
enough students entering College who say
I don't really know what I want to do
that if you said but I'll give you a
scholarship I'm going to loan you money
for a business you don't know you want
to start yetes make any sense if if I
was saying oh there's a nursing short
right or there's um I don't I don't know
what is specific types someone who works
with you know elderly people and I said
you know you go to college right Boomers
us get real old uh if you go to college
for this thing I will give you the money
for it you have to graduate with this
degree and go into that field that would
make way more sense to me than the
government saying no worries you may
English literature you got it yeah and I
did get a degree in now I'm just kidding
uh that's the thing it doesn't it
doesn't make sense uh and ultimately I
don't understand why the federal
government logically would be supporting
this unless they know ultimately they're
able to pull strings and have
universities back sort of Nefarious
schemes that they have they have uh
contrived to pull off against the
American people if I had not been able
to get a loan for theater or for
whatever General I did like
Communications and journalism and then
theater but I could have got a loan for
like a math degree I would have got a
math degree cuz I didn't have the money
I couldn't have gone to college without
a loan or what if they didn't give you a
loan for anything and you just went and
got a job you might be working conr
theater local theater went up to
Cleveland done theater in Cleveland
that's kind of what I was doing anyway
part of my day would be that 30 seconds
between the car and your front
door Goodwill Hunting when I knock and
you're not
there you should be you shouldn't be a
construction worker you should be doing
exactly what you're doing beautiful
Talent right here let's let's jump to
this story ladies and gentlemen we got
the official word from CBS News Trump
would win a rematch against Biden if the
election was held right now CBS News
poll says and I think it's not just the
CBS News poll I think there's a there's
a bunch of other polls showing this here
here you go from Tim cast.com Trump
leads Biden in five out of six key
Battleground States new poll finds the
polling results for registered voters in
Arizona Georgia Michigan Nevada and
Pennsylania show Biden losing to Trump
by margins of 4 to 10 points holy crap
this is coming from the New York Times
so I think this is a different poll
across six Battlegrounds all of which Mr
Biden carried in 2020 the president
Trails by an average of 48 to 44% of the
times reported the results show
significant discontent with Biden as
policy over the past three years across
both genders and all ages races
education levels and income brackets a
majority of respondents said that
Biden's policy have hurt them personally
I mean you were just talking to us about
somebody who said they voted for Biden
and that he sucks yeah I was at a
restaurant and the waitress asked me
about my Alex Jones was right shirt that
I'm wearing and then we started talking
about politics and she said I voted for
Biden but I think he's terrible I'm not
going to vote for him she didn't say she
was going to vote for Trump mind you
right but that's the first time in my
life I've really experienced just like a
stranger saying they regret who they
vote for I mean I'm sure it's happened
before and I haven't been alive through
that many presidential election Cycles
but I really do think it's not just a
right-wing talking point to say that the
people who voted for Biden are
disappointed I think that that's
actually the truth and this is why they
this is why Biden ran they needed a
sacrificial goat a Corporal form aoral
form of some sort knowing that they were
going to cause a bunch of problems
Trump made America better whether or not
he made it great again is entirely up to
your opinion but the economy was a
booming Co happened I'm not going to
blame Trump or Biden for Co having
happened but we can certainly criticize
them over their policies but things were
going really really well under Trump
despite the fact that they strapped some
heavy Russia gate uh uh weights to his
legs and we're trying to pin him down
nobody got in trouble for that either
really right but but things were great
in 2019 the best numbers of Our Lives
Jim Kramer man that guy's wrong about
everything but he sure nailed that one
nah it was infl everything was inflating
like rapidly inflating so it looked good
on paper but we were headed towards a
cliff massive happened happened after
the pandemic though making an argument
that on the books things were bad is
different from saying the average person
was enjoying record low unemployment
their rages were going up they the
economy was in full motion people were
going to this go store my business was
booming business was booming for
everybody the local contractors we had
in Jersey were like man this has been
the best year of my life I went to the
furniture store to buy the first
equipment the first table for Tim cast
IRL and the lady was like it she was so
happy when I bought everything she was
like this has been the best year for me
no question I paid off all my debt 2019
and what happens then they vote for
Biden and everything gets worse and
people are longing for 2019 again well
we should ask we should ask Ron Paul how
great the economy was in 2019 before we
decide the I was going to say the Biden
campaign is aware that they're in
trouble they put out a memo last
Thursday saying we're expecting you know
close a tight race but we'll be able to
Def whoever comes out of the I think
they said Maga extremist race so they
think it's going to be Trump too but
they are openly warning their own people
that this is going to be close I mean
they are not even able to fake it
amongst themselves that they have this
in the bag and I think that really has
to speak to people's experience with
Biden in office right I'm not an e I'm
not an economic expert I can't tell you
exactly who did what that caused all the
problems I do know that under Biden uh
gas has gone up and it's extremely
expensive and also which means that
everything goes up at the stores because
the cost of shipping is higher so
groceries go way up because of the gas
prices oh
my someone someone chatted this and uh a
McDouble at McDonald's is $3.30 I don't
Mac for 18 bucks was in this week right
I don't eat a McDonald's the last time I
ate a McDonald's a McChicken and a
McDouble or a buck you got to wear a
tuxedo to go in now they have a dress
code wow did you is that real that a Big
Mac you're joking right it's 18 bucks in
some markets they they vary the the the
price whoa so my our local McDonald's
it's 1019 for a Big Mac meal what and
the McDouble is 330 and the McChicken is
330 there was a video I saw on on
Instagram this week of a guy buying
groceries at Whole Foods and he was like
when I bought this in 2019 it cost me
$72 when I bought the same exact things
you know in I don't remember how many
years before it cost me around $62 and
then he went in and bought all the exact
thing he showing their re seat and it
was like
$115 I mean it's just obvious how
quickly Things Are Climbing and the
thing is the basic American voter can't
say oh well this policy or this bill
they can say for the past three years
under under Joe Biden despite being
promised that things would get better
despite being promised in loan debt
forgiveness despite being promised this
that and the other all I know is that he
blames Trump but things are worse under
him and that's what's going to speak to
them when they go to the polls well what
we need to do is improve our fuel source
and use hydrogen whoever wants to win
the presidency should hire me and I will
make that happen uh I don't even want
any money Energy Secretary I don't care
about the money I just want to make it
happen because it it's the fuel costs
that are making this go out of control
it all start stems from the fuel cost
rut down the Ukrainian pipeline that's
that that is a component of it but Mass
spending and the uh the the billions of
dollars going to Foreign Wars what what
basically happens is when the US
government gives your money away they
are both simultaneously taking your
taxes and spending it but also inflating
the the cost of goods by stripping
resources away they're they're ripping
the buying your buying power from your
sa confirming customer calls up
McDonald's pricing after being charg 18
bucks for a Big Mac meal the the head
just for yeah it was for the full meal
it's from yahoo.com and I think New York
Post also reported on it $18 in in
Connecticut for a ladies and gentlemen
this na guys this is the apocalypse for
Joe Biden because I tell you this
McDonald's was supposed to be you walk
in you grab your garbage food you walk
out you're drunk after going to the bar
and your buddies are like let's get some
you know McDoubles or whatever but if
you're walking in and you're like oh man
I want the McDonald's fries in a Big Mac
and they're like that'll be $20 so
you're like wait what does somebody want
to split it with me no I guess not
they're going to walk out and be like
thanks Joe Biden yeah yeah that's not
McDonald's fault this is what the I
can't remember his name but the CEO of
Costco sort of won a lot of f uh a lot
of fans because he said you will not
raise the price of our hot dog yes even
if it costs us money even if it costs us
money because people number one
appreciate that but then also there are
people who legitimately want to come in
there and be like we're going to get
some food after trying to save money on
our groceries it it is something they
are doing out of loyalty to the public I
mean that's that is one of the stories
that I remember coming out of Co the
most which is that there were CEOs who
were like I'm going to foro my salary
for the year to keep our waitresses
employed but but it's also probably more
simple it's much more simple than that
the Costco said hey the cost of hot dogs
is going up so we got to raise the
prices and the other guy probably said
people come to Costco Costco knowing
they're going to get a dollar hot dog
and a pretzel it's an investment and and
they're going to then shop at our store
and they if you raise that price you
will lose there are some gas stations
that lose money on the gas that they
sell just because they want to come in
and buy a pack of cigarettes and play
snacks and stuff like that well and I'm
sure with Costco too if you raise the
hot dogs everyone's going to be like
well is it even worth being a member
here everything is going the hot dogs
tell us that everything is you are
saving money when you go there happens
Trump needs to come out and start
complaining about the cost of a Big Mac
and that's a good idea it is I mean
because you're going to be look Big Mac
will be $111 when when you come out and
you say the stock market is doing really
really great people are like I don't I
don't know what that means to me regular
Americans are not in the stock market
when you go and say your price of of gas
they know that but what are they feeling
right now you see Biden drains the
Strategic petroleum Reserve to try and
keep prices low to force a market shift
but you can't do nothing about that Big
Mac Biden can't release the Big Macs
from the Strategic Reserve to keep the
Big Mac prices down and regular
Americans don't have time to cook want
to stop on the way on the way to work
grab a Big Mac or the way home from work
traditionally you think about it as the
cheapest fast food option too so this is
definitely targeting a blue Coller sort
of trying to save money I need a study
right now on the price increase across
everything cuz I feel like Taco Bell is
actually going get the best deal I feel
like they are probably well we've been
living moss and I've not noticed uh let
me let me let me let me check out our
local Taco Bell and see what our prices
are I mean it was definitely like up
compared to cuz we you know we didn't I
haven't eat before this past like month
we did not eat any Taco Bell in a really
long time tell me that it's not more
than $149 for a hard taco dude it is
going to cry always get the pack it's
like going to cry you want man they used
to be 49 cents they'd be like 79 cents
but then they'd go down to 49 on like a
Tuesday when then like meat comes out 10
tacos in yeah Taco Bell's up there now
too man you're going to you're going to
cry you well hydrogen fuel can actually
be transported through the methane
system through the natural gas system so
it's like the the system's already in
place to deliver it according to James
tour is crazy what is it a Taco Bell
prices a hard a nacho cheese Dorito taco
is
365 I'm sorry but a McDouble is better
deal than that mhm k fiesta potatoes are
some Economist who can do a study on me
like what is the best value fast food
meal out there if this already exists
someone could send that to me that'd be
really cool Kell lison coming in through
the ether saying Chick-fil-A breakfast
is pretty cheap delicious too I can't
confirm ory okay that's the thing I
believe it's I believe it's delicious
but I need to see a study I need some
analysis done this is a p that's the
thing if you want it you'll probably buy
it anyways but you will pay in other way
we got to get Trump talking about
hydrogen we started dying over here if
if hump starts being hydrogen fuel we're
retro fitting the economy graphine we're
retrofitting it doesn't even matter if
he wins if we can get Trump talking
about it Non-Stop and excited it's going
to excite a bunch of other politicians
to start talking about it just to keep
up so so those were delivery prices
which are are are are way higher but no
Nao cheese taco is $3 directly from the
store and a crunchy taco is a buck 80 oh
it's over 159 that was my fear 149 159
180 anything being that cheap I feel
like I just didn't grow up I remember
when the dollar menu was a dollar I
remember when you get a mid chicken for
9 ents 99 Cents that's crazy yeah it
years ago mid90s was when I was at it I
feel like dollar menu is like a
euphemism like close dollar the dollar
dollar store it's like actually
everything's $5 it's going to be funny
when called the dime store Trump's going
to be on a debate with Biden is going to
be like the cheesy Gordina crunch is
five bucks it was 329 when I wasid was
329 in 2019 Joe Biden the price is down
we got to get we got to get an interview
with that guy did has that have The
Feelers gone out Cassandra we got to do
this now we just need there's no time to
wait in fact there is no time time is
not a real thing it's a concept motion
is everything and we're every time we
talk to uh you know we have people on
the show who are like either working
directly for Trump they're always like
yes of course just like let us know and
we're like yeah okay and then like you
know I don't know they just had the big
party at Mar Lago didn't did you go
chase no I wasn't invited it was like
for uh uh police state yeah oh yeah with
thees yeah's new documentary we had him
on in for talking about that sounds
really good it looks really good yeah I
think we're going to be doing something
with him with the NES
soon I don't want to say too much until
I know it's confirmed but is it is it
confirmed Serge just shaking his head
yes oh okay all right we're we're we're
going to be we're gonna dases is coming
on at some point he a great guy yeah he
is we're going to DC for a screening and
then we're going to do a show so that'll
be really cool he was fun to have on the
culture War he's great yeah he's a good
dude yeah he's real like kind of simple
like an easygoing guy I mean he's super
brilliant complex thinker but like just
a simple normal dude to talk to
one-onone very accessible uh okay so
we're going to get Trump involved and
make him talk about hydrogen no he's
going to make himself talk about
hydrogen I just can't imagine being Joe
Biden's campaign right now like he's not
going to be able to come out there and
say I got ice cream Scoops at my Beach
in Delaware it cost me $50 don't worry
Americans speaking of no no listen
here's the here's the story from
Politico fresh Revelations contradict
Joe Biden's sweeping denials on Hunter
the corporate press is coming out
against Joe Biden we know what's going
to happen repace Donald Trump is going
to come out and say that Taco Bell is
too expensive and Big Macs are 18 bucks
and then the Democrats are going to get
rid of Joe Biden and this is how they do
it yep do you think that they're going
to do you think that there's going to be
like a terrorist attack here in the
United States within the next 12 months
yes but it'll be like Hamas related or
Hamas inspired as an excuse to both get
us into World War III and get Joe Biden
out for his border policy so they can
just replace him at the last second I
think based on the reporting we've seen
from a very simple uh a very simple
assessment if you trust the the
government which I don't know why you
would but assuming you did did they're
telling you that there is a a risk of of
Terror happening in in in in this next
year if you are a I don't know
pessimistic Politico you're probably
like oh yeah I mean the Border has been
ripped to shreds they're capturing
people in the ter uh the terror watch
list down there so yes we're at Great
risk the probability is decent now as
for if it connects to Joe Biden in World
War II I don't know about that but I do
not see Joe Biden being the nominee for
the Democratic party either how they get
rid of how they get him out yeah this is
not the best way to do it
accusing the Dem Joe Biden of corruption
that's going to lead to a trump Victory
even if you bring in Nome but if Joe
Biden has some kind of like medical
episode and Gavin Newsome runs on a
stage and saves his life now Gavin
Newsome's the front runner and that's a
clean exit for Joe Biden I think the
clean exit is ideal for both parties
this was Mutual the fact that it's so
much so many Hunter Revelations makes me
think that the Biden Camp is resisting
and they're going to go Kicking and
Screaming so they have to destroy him
because he won't go quietly and so
they're say would just be to Pardon him
for everything though then they would
stop investigating because it would be
moot no the issue is the Deep State goes
to I guess the theory is the Deep state
would go to Joe Biden and say hey we'd
like you to bow out not run for second
term and we're going to bring in Nome
and Joe Biden says no I can do it man
come on I'm I'm I'm not I'm good for it
and they're like Joe we're telling you
we're not going to let you do this and
he goes you can't stop me and so they're
like we're going to we're going to have
to forcefully this guy removed that's
how I felt the first couple years that
they were asking him like do you think
you're going to run and he was like yeah
yeah for sure and then in JN Pierre or
whoever was in maybe jump be like oh
they're talking about it they're
thinking about it like there was
obviously some sort of uh disagreement
internally and yet Biden is still
announced you know via video that he was
going to run again and that's when you
saw an increase in the pressure on H
Biden I mean the fact that the
mainstream media is now willing to talk
about it is like this very bitter pill
because ultimately it means they don't
actually care about this at all they
care about something else and we'll find
out about it in six months I think he's
going to exit the presidential race like
he exited Afghanistan and a
humiliating surrender he will have to
Pardon his kid first that'll be like the
sign that you know that it's over is
when you hear that Hunter's getting
pardoned and then like in a week you're
going to hear that he's not I don't
think he I mean he's a 100,000 years old
anyways but he couldn't run again if he
pardoned his own kid he was born like
three years after the air conditioning
was invented for the automobile there
was some yeah there was some study there
was like he was born closer to the sil I
can't remember what it was I don't want
to misquote it but closer to the Civil
War Cil War than today he was old enough
to he was potty trained by the time
Hitler died so he's old enough to
remember when Hitler was still on the
radio was born in 42 wow yeah November
20th hey his birthday's coming up I mean
and that I I feel like we should be
honest obviously Trump is is older too
but he doesn't slur and Shuffle the way
Joe Biden does yeah it's cular age he's
way younger yeah and I think that's I
mean this is it's not true anymore it
was true the year a couple years ago
okay cuz he was born 77 years after the
end of the Civil War so when he was 76
he was born closer oh wait no no no no
it's actually true now I be true right I
mean it would always be true once it
becomes true right so no no I was wrong
no it is
true wow it was 77 years from the Civil
War and he's what is he 78 78 yeah oh no
he took took office at the age of 78
yeah right so that yeah you were right I
was wrong no it is true now I'm he he
was born closer to the Civil War than to
today right than like from his birth Ian
this is just how time works but then to
be like and this is the guy leading our
country this is the guy who can't
remember anything definitely be like if
you have to be at least you should have
to be not over 65 or 75 it was honestly
one of Mitt Romney's best political
moments when he announced he was going
to retire rather continue to see terms
because he was like if I run again I
will be in my 80s and that's too old and
you know that that's not a terrible
Point again I'm not saying that Trump
shouldn't run I'm not saying that
everyone who's in their 80 is in the
position Joe Biden is in but we can't
say that we're like this young spry
country there was a reason that JFK had
such an influence on politics right that
he was young he had these kids a
beautiful wife whatever else well Trump
is spry well and this was one of the
appeals for santis in the beginning
people were comparing him you know to
this young he's got young children
whatever else got a young wife there was
sort of this idea that it was sort of a
brush of FR a this was before I think
Trump announced obviously there's more
contention now I'm not trying to weigh
on on that got on his heels but then
Biden ha but then uh uh not Biden then
Des santis showed up to school wearing
high heels and everyone went hey look
new kids wearing high heels and he went
shut up no I'm not I want to bring this
up I was thinking about this before the
show so um Ren he's in Iowa right now
and he's doing this you know
uh rally with Kim Reynolds and there's a
picture of him so it's Casey Ronda
santis and then the governor of Iowa and
her husband and Casey Anthony is wearing
sneakers and I then tried to pull a
photo of her in heels and they are
weirdly always the same height diff
difference even when she's in heels and
in secret there's a there's a meme photo
showing Ronda santis walking on the
beach Barefoot with his wife and he's
got the same height Advantage then
there's a photo of her wearing high
heels and he has the same height
Advantage it doesn't make sense like
that I just Ed some science to F out
there was like a moment I was sitting in
my office comparing pictures of them in
different
shoes this was an easy catch either she
needs to always be in heels we maintain
this height difference or she can never
wear sneak I don't think the problem is
that he short though like I think he
should have just leaned into it like hey
you know statistics show that if you
perceived as short it's a disadvantage
so I just try to you know fit the bill
like debate on podiums they always
someone super chatted that when Patrick
Bet David questioned him on the on the
high heels and said how how tall are you
he should have went well I identify as
6'2 and then everyone would have that
would have been the
smoo instead he was like what are you
talking about I'm not wearing high heels
it just boots a butt off the wreck like
every other normal person does I am
human yeah he was he even said he he
hadn't seen the meme which is like yo
been out for a week or his or his team
was too scared to show him what did he
say it's no time for foot fetishes is
that he got yeah some interviewer he
lost the foot
vote that's a very controversial opinion
to take man there's a bunch of guys on
wik feet being like Ron's lost my vote
this is it says Casey to santis is 55 or
5'9 depending on the source wow maybe
she should come on the show because I'm
5'9 so this is why he this is why he
won't come on the show because we're
going to be like take the boots off we
we we have a fine carpet household here
literally I'm wearing socks right now
just so you know I don't have shoes on
we should we should Implement you don't
need to hold your feet up but I already
did it no we just have
toar because our carpets uh you know we
we they get cleaned every week and uh
but to preserve longevity no shoes
policy so Ron please come on the show
and no shoes I mean I would love it
would be funny if he took his shoes off
and his feet are just shaped like that
like Big Blocks like he just has he has
really thick heels AC figure did you at
every point that would be a really funny
bit actually he takes the boots off and
his feet are just gigantic triangles
were you supporting him at any way
before at any point I always thought
that he was a good Governor but I knew
that I was going to vote for Trump as
soon as they started prosecuting him so
I was sort of somebody that hadn't made
a decision yet but as soon as they
really started coming down with the
prosecutions it's like I'm going to vote
for the guy that they hate most what do
you think about V I like V I had him on
my podcast um he's obviously been on
infow Wars recently with Alex I think
that V is a very bright very honest guy
that is positioning himself for some
other reason than to be president I
think he wants to be in second everybody
in the Republican side wants to be in
second place because if Trump gets de
balloted then it's like it there's got
to be somebody else right and so I think
that was kind of the original thing but
what he really seems to be pulling for
me is a campaign of awareness but also
he could be easily put in some sort of a
cabinet position after and he's been
very smart in that he's been the only
candidate on the right who hasn't come
out and criticized Trump directly and
you never want to attack a stronger
enemy head on I think the reason to
santis is losing so badly is because his
campaign strategy was to attack a
stronger enemy headon just come after
Trump seething right away that was very
stupid V has never once insulted Trump
when I asked him he said that he thought
Trump was a great president he just
thinks it's time for somebody else just
very vanilla and that's why you never
see Trump Bash in V but he'll batch all
the other candidates but not V because
V's never been a dick to him yeah yeah
that's a good point that's very sunu mhm
yeah it seems like despite what V is
saying he's he's going for the for the
VP or the next cycle or something yeah
he'd be a great VP he would be because
he's a I mean uh vake is is is sharp as
they come i' I've watched I watch a
bunch of his Clips on on Instagram and
Twitter when he does interviews and I'm
just like man well he he had a brilliant
strategy he did like three podcasts a
day for six months so he comes off
sounding so polished like Obama did but
Obama got there because of the focus
groups the got there because he's
answered the same questions 1,700 times
because he's been done so many
appearances so he's just got the right
answer for everything and he's high IQ
sharp guy I don't think I know he made
money from some Soros fund or whatever
at one point I know he's invested in big
farm at one point but I don't think he
sold out to them I don't I don't believe
I don't care I don't care if someone
does right if if if you meet like if
David hog tomorrow came out and said in
tears that he's looking at these
statistics and he and he can't believe
how wrong he was and and he wants to
dedicate his time to fighting for gun
rights would people be like no no some
people would but I'd be like this is
fantastic a guy with a million followers
and now all a so if the did do things
you don't like but now he's saying all
the right things keep encouraging to say
WF and W because they didn't they make
him a young Global leader he's like I
never gave you my approval for that and
that's the thing like you if David hog
came out and was like I'm actually for
gun rights now I would say please show
me the gun you have recently purchased
and so I can believe you are actually
committed to this cause I mean there is
one thing to say I've changed my mind
there's to actually prove and
consistently behave as though you have
changed your mind I would go buy a gun
with David hog that' be a good do love
that as a uh as content on YouTube I
feel like that would be really
interesting who wouldn't go buy a gun or
not YouTube X or whatever we're into now
I probably if somebody wanted to go buy
a gun and I was thinking about buying a
gun I'd probably do it with them if they
wanted to yeah Greta yeah for sure we
could talk about gun rights and how
they're awesome the second amendment's
legit it is quite indeed oh speaking of
Second Amendment the infringe
documentary is officially up tomorrow at
9:00 a.m. 12 hours Southern yeah and
we'll be doing a big old ad campaign
promoting it so uh let me just say to
all of you listening when you go to
timcast doom and you become a member
what do we do we uh uh commission Lauren
Southern and John dtoa is am I
pronouncing his name right to so I'm
like I don't know I a French D and uh
they do excellent work and that was a
very expensive uh a very expensive
project with all the travel and all the
people and all the scheduling and uh
then we're also going to be dumping
large large amounts of money into
marketing that documentary all over the
place and it is a documentary explaining
the importance I I shouldn't put it that
way but it's about gun rights it's
called infringe and explains the purpose
and the point it talks a lot about the
issue of guns from a very I would say
proun perspective I saw the trailer is
the trailers public at this point I
think there's a couple clips from it
already up on youtube.com/ timcast as
well as some trailers and then we've got
uh three different short trailers coming
up I like the way they framed it because
it they really highlighted the dangers
of like mass shooting and gun violence
and then it sounds like then they start
to talk about why it's important to
protect your rights and defend yourself
from that stuff it's really simple
actually a centralized security
apparatus does not work the idea that
you can give all of your security to one
organization in one location is an
absurdity eight at the very least argue
8020 right that 20% of the security is
handled by the individual and 80% by the
apparatus I'm not even saying that I'm
saying at minimum the idea that only
police will have guns means criminals
will have guns because clearly they're
in violation of the law and as the
saying goes when seconds matter police
are minutes away right and this is why
we experience more uh this is why the
study showed that in uh gunfree zones
people are less likely to stop a mass
shooter and everywhere else excluding
gunfree zones 51% of shootings were
stopped by a good a person law legally a
lot of mass shooter shootings happen in
gun in gun-free zones like they happen
in places like schools and I had a dream
last night that we meet a group and I
went to protect these people and we got
there and they were like okay someone's
got to stay to protect the kids the
children and I was like okay I'll do it
so I stayed there but all I had was a
knife and I was just there with the kids
and then this guy came and he had a
shotgun it was like one of those pump
action automatic semi-automatic shotguns
and I was like trying to to dodge him
around the the couch and I ran around
the edge and he just shot me in the face
I was like damn it and then I was still
alive in the dream and I was like I need
a done I cannot I cannot defend myself
in these kids without one I heard you
can't die in dreams I didn't yeah I
don't I've never really died true I
think you wake up no I've died in dreams
before and just been dead but like it
just the dream keeps going in a
different way I I i' I've had tons of
Dreams where I've died you die and
you're just laying there and like
everybody's hanging out no no like I had
a dream where there was a nuclear
explosion and then everyone died and
then all of a sudden I was still in my
dream doing something else like I it's
like oh wow we all died in nuclear
explosion but but we're still just like
in a different building now I don't know
how did you know that you died so I had
a dream where we were in a car and there
was like we saw like an ICBM coming like
ah and then like a nuke went off and
then I was it was like it was like a
nightmare it was like a scary feeling
and then there's like a wall of like
white light and then all of a sudden
it's just me and other people were in a
room and we're like wow I can't believe
we all died in that nuclear explosion
and then just like you were in the lobby
of like heaven something like that I
don't know maybe but in dreams things
don't make sense and you don't realize
things are happening so it's just like
it car on and then I woke up like wo
that was a crazy dream I love that
relief when you get killed in your dream
and you're like oh I'm not really dead
this is awesome see Dre so Ian's died in
his dream I had this dream all the time
where I need to shoot somebody and I
don't have the strength to pull the
trigger you ever had that dream you're
yeah in my dream I couldn't bring myself
to stab the guy because I didn't want to
get blood all over the place I'm like
what
isong that's not it it's the idea called
punching in a dream yeah you can't exert
Force because of it's something to do
with the chemical that paralyzes your
body so you move really slow you can't
run properly and also something about
because of because of the way like your
brain works in dreams you can't read
either and so uh when it comes to lucid
dreaming one of the techniques is to try
and read so there's a bunch of things
you can do but you can uh uh if you want
to read about one of them is when you
read something and it's gibberish you
should you should realize you're
dreaming there's a bunch of there's a
bunch of other other trips too Biden's
inaugural speech I always notice if
you're ever in a dream and you can't get
out and you want to get out close your
eyes really tight tight until you can
feel it and as soon as you feel it when
you open them you'll be awake because
it's that feeling that wakes you up I
mean everybody's different when I
usually want to wake up I just wake up I
don't know it's like excellent
self-discipline Dam yeah I just wake up
I'm like oh wow I was having a bad dream
I've had dreams where I think I have
woken up and so I can picture my room
and stuff like that but I am actually
still asleep and I think this is often
because I have to set up a lot of alarm
so you're sort of waking up and you're
immediately falling back to sleep the
dream where you like get up and get take
a shower and get dressed and you're like
on your way to work and then all a
sudden you wake up I got to do it all
again turns out none of that is real
very frustrating I do think it's funny
that nightmares are depicted in media as
like being attacked by monsters or like
chased by a killer when in reality
nightmares are like you have a dream
that you miss you're late for work yeah
you know it's like my nightmares are
like I woke up at 8:30 and I'm like oh
crap and I'm like trying to get dressed
real fast and I'm like I'm anxiety like
I got to get up there I got to record oh
man and then I wake up and at 7:00 and
I'm like ah
Brin just like feeling stressed out
let's see what happens I used to have
this dream that I uh would get to the
last day or like exams when I was in
college and realized that I had
forgotten about a class I had signed up
for for the entire semester I had that
dream before it was extreme I always
found it very not graduating dream it's
not even that I wouldn't graduate it's
just like suddenly you realized you were
supposed to be either you would fail
this class because you had to go take
the exam but actually you had never
taken the class and you didn't realize
you funny I had that dream like twice a
year I thought I was the only one crazy
where I would be on stage but for the
play that I never rehearsed for like I
got all these lines and I don't know any
of them literally it's the most imar
like let's 10,000 people watching or
whatever 5,000 people well hard segue
back to news we have this uh tweet this
is a viral video it's going around
Hammer attack on a painting in the
National Gallery in London oh ladies and
gentlemen we got to watch it and there
is so much to be said about this video
here we
go we got a two people
smashing the glass in the painting did
not get the vote by voting it is time
for deeds and not words it is time to
just stop
oil politics is failing us politics
filled women in
1914 if Millions will die due to new oil
and gas licensing
Millions if we love history if we love
art and if we love our families we must
just stop
oil here's here's where it gets sad they
go and sit down now wait wait for the
most the most depressing moment and it's
right there oh he loves her you don't
just join the movement cuz he's really
attractive to freaking theater kids of
the wild no she she grabs his hand now
I'm sorry life this what I tweet I said
life must be really hard when you're an
effing idiot says he so there's glass on
this painting and they're not using just
hammers it looks like they're using this
emergency hammers that I think have uh
special material for breaking glass that
makes sense yeah and they're trying to
damage the painting but I don't think
they're able to because these are very
very well protected paintings but you
see I'm I'm sorry my friends he says
millions of people will die because of
these gas
leases we must just stop oil it is very
basic and simple
Common Sense the irony that if you stop
producing oil
dozens of people will die Millions
dozens of tens of millions 60 million
people will die in 3 days in the United
States in Europe because oil is used to
produce food to create electricity
instantly we talk about this all the
time the diabetics die overnight without
Refrigeration without the production of
oil he would not be wearing a hat he not
be wearing glasses he likely wouldn't be
wearing those jeans the of his shoes the
wouldn't be getting laid the estimate
well no I mean if they got it that chick
would be all about it but they're both
so insane cultists being used for
political purposes they don't even
bother Google searching this it's like
hey guy what what what fuel is used to
drive the tractor is it produced from
oil or the bus that brought you here yo
they tried doing electric farm equipment
and it's just like people are like are
you nuts it doesn't work electric trucks
they're already having problems with it
because maybe we get to the point when
we have ubiquitous graphine Polymer
batteries and we can recharge an
electric vehicle in 30 seconds like you
can refill a gas tank maybe and it's
possible but right now we use oil for
everything humans a large portion of
this planet exists simply because oil
exists yeah the re you know you you can
actually track the oil age and the
population boom all of a sudden we
discovered we started discovering oil
and uses for it and then the population
skyrockets then you get the 50s and the
petrochemical boom and we're kind of
like the unabashed burning of oil is not
good if we never stopped just burning it
all and putting things into it and
burning them into the atmosphere we'd
probably all choke and die but we're not
doing that we're reusing the carbon so
we don't need to stop using it we need
to reuse the carbon dude Alex Epstein
wrote an awesome book about this I don't
know if you guys have ever had him on
the show he would be an awesome guest he
wrote a book called fossil future and it
was basically making the case that just
what you said more people would die if
we actually did these green energy deals
and if we did this because the third
world countries are the ones that rely
on fossil fuels the most even though
they're not the greatest culprit of
pollution but they rely on it the most
because it's the cheapest form of energy
so if you're going to when we do things
internationally like force third world
countries to obey our sort of green
standards in exchange for funding and
money and stuff it actually could lead
to a catastrophic amount of death for
people that rely on things like gas for
heat it's I don't know if I don't know
if I you could say it's the cheapest
it's the highest energy return so uh you
know AA was form of energy you can use a
cow to pull you know Tom farming
equipment to like sew you know to like
you know Harvest a field or something
like that but you know that's not as
efficient as oil so it's that you get
way more energy out of oil now look
there there's an issue you if you look
at global population it's very steady
and then right at the turn of the
century 1900s it skyrockets and just
goes exponential and that's due to oil
we were all of a sudden able to
mass-produce food much much more quickly
everyone became very fat and happy and
people have lots and lots of babies and
so this results in a massive population
boom around the world but now because
the oil went up people go up if the oil
goes down the people go down and so that
means if you just stop oil you're going
to kill dozens of millions tens of
millions we can all admit this was
incredibly lazy they they came up with
this fun slogan just stop oil they put
on a bunch of t-shirts they got their
little tool to maget Glass I mean I miss
that guy who super glued himself to a
Starbucks cter like these people are
like they brought a friend to film
hopefully he is that was way more how do
they pick the painting that's my
question like all right we got to have a
strategico the lighting is really good
here you stand over there and we'll sit
here and it'll be great I mean I just
feel like this had no it it's it's not
even that passionate offense so it's no
wonder that they have no idea what
they're arguing for because all they're
doing is trying to get clout on social
media there what are we looking at just
stop oil.com I mean what what are they
even arguing who sees that and changes
their mind we just watched it if someone
sees them it's like wow I love these
young activists doing something I would
be surprised if it turns out that justop
oil was funded by a bunch of oil
companies indirectly to I'm not kidding
it's brilliant psychology it's not it's
I wouldn't even call it brilliant I call
it
basic like if if if you get a guy if you
get a guy in a trump in a trump shirt
and he walks around screaming he's all
super drunk and he's screaming and then
he walks up to a guy who's waving a
little flag saying help help us uh uh
Joe Biden wants to help us save puppies
and then the Trump guy hits the Biden
guy and it's on video who does that
benefit not benefit Trump right people
are G to be like oh wow those Trump
supporters are crazy this by any metric
to any social media marketing person
they filmed
this social media marketing 101 if you
are the aggressor you are viewed
negatively and benefit the the the
inverse false Flags so what they're
doing is benefiting oil companies they
look unreasonable they look unhinged
they've been what what you have those
people blocking the roads that's not
going to convin that makes people angry
so all these I I seriously believe oil
companies are like let's indirectly fund
these anti-oil NOS to make people
despise the oil protesters that makes
sense to me I mean when I see stuff I
think about these pieces of art that if
someone really destroyed them we would
lose them forever right it's similar
argument you make with like the
Confederate monuments right those were a
form of art that once destroyed can
never come back and so maybe you feel
really passionate about this issue but
this is a very lame protest to me that
could potentially destroy something that
has nothing to do with anything else of
course they don't care they don't care
about anything but if you're a viewer it
doesn't make me want to support their
cause we got to refocus it onto reusing
the waste the the fuel waste you got
fuel you have three types of fuel
there's hydrogen carbon and plutonium
those are the only things that can
function is fuel the difference between
what fuel is means it can be put into a
container and moved around carried
around everything else like wind
turbines solar panels they're not types
of fuel they're just types of energy
generation but you need to reuse the
fuel waste so the carbon dioxide or for
plutonium they've got spent nuclear fuel
is what they called and I'm actually
interviewing a guy tomorrow on my
YouTube channel at 2:00 p.m. Eastern who
funds companies that are investing in uh
reusing plutonium spent nuclear fuel
turning them into things like I don't
know if he's going deep into the graph
into the um Diamond batteries nuclear
waste Diamond batteries where you put it
inside of carbon and it can produce like
10,000 years of electrical charge your
phone never needs a charge always be on
crazy right as long as we focus on
reusing the waste of fuel we're going to
be okay we can keep using the fuel Ian
can I ask you a question that's off
topic if you had to propose to a girl
and buy her an aent rank would you make
graphine the center stone with the whole
thing be out of graphine graphine is uh
is a single Atomic sheet okay but how
would you incorporate graine because I
feel like that's the only material I
could see you using it's it's such an
important part of your advocacy uh I'd
get a platinum gold silver probably a
platinum gold palladium ring like three
metal bands with a diamond so no
graphine at all I obviously don't I
don't know enough if graphine is safe to
have in skin contact for long periods of
time oh just carbon D I talked to a
chemist before I did that but that's
kind of a cool idea shirts or something
I have one on right now this is graphine
spandex my pants are actually graphine
as well that's crazy uh it's cool they
they stay second foot of the episode I
do want to disclose I did invest in a
graphine manufacturer I fully intend to
monetize off of uh Ian's constant
Shilling Universal matter sure but in
all seriousness when Ian started ranting
about graphine I did buy stock in a in a
graphine company a long time ago and
it's it's like one of my only stocks
that's improved I would recommend
checking out universal matter.com it's
uh James tour one of James tour's
companies where they're flashing the
graphine with electric they're flashing
carbon with electricity and producing
graphine with it and they're mass mass
mass producing it so this this flash
Jewel heating is the future can graphine
be used to make annoying oil protesters
stop smashing things and throwing paint
on people not even graphine is that
powerful unfortunate maybe maybe you
could improve the roads
uh uh you could actually make a graphine
cover to that painting that they
couldn't crack through every time they
hit it they got electrocut they would
just find some other way of being
annoyed about something else like this
is the personality type they came with a
prepared monologue and someone to film
them like he L the practice sessions
though that's the wor that's the saddest
thing for that guy about this event was
that he doesn't get to rehearse anymore
well the saddest thing about it is that
he rehearses kids but he didn't Google
one time anything that he was saying it
could help them he doesn't care about it
intoing it it it it like holds it so it
doesn't get out into the atmosphere like
turning carbon into graphing you don't
it's so solid of a material that you
don't lose it in probably went to a
meeting he met her at a bar and she's
like well I'm going to ajust up oil
protest like so am I me me too I'll be
there and that's that's probably the
only reason he's there yeah that makes
sense I mean this was one of the stories
that I liked from last year which is a
lot of the get out the vote efforts
where young women who were on they would
set their dating app profiles to
whatever City they were trying to get
people to register vote in for their you
know Progressive cause and they would
just like talk to guys like wow you're
so cute are you voting maybe like it'd
be cool if you registered to vote and
here's a little bit about this candidate
that I'm supporting it's kind of weird
wasn't it typically the men who would
try and Court the females by doing a
weird dance but now the women are doing
the weird dance to court the males on
behalf of a politician it's super creepy
I hate it do you think there was some of
that going on with the Israel related
protest that we saw a couple days ago on
DC I mean this goes on with all protest
seemed like a lot of college kids and a
lot of dudes I'm like what is that dude
doing there I'm like oh he's probably
there for some girl right it's like you
ever watch it so Sunny yeah sometimes
the the abortion episode where he's like
pretending that he's pro-choice or
whatever cuz he's just trying to get
laid and then he's thinking like they
must be easy or whatever and then what
happens he's he tells the woman the
pro-life woman he's pretending he's pro
life and then when she gets pregnant
he's like oh you got get an abortion
like never pro life at all I haven't
seen that one that's hysterical yeah
it's one of their super old ones from
like 20 years ago yeah class but this is
the thing I feel like men should just be
more like no I don't like that and the
girls would eventually it might you know
might not happen as fast but yeah but
they would change their minds and listen
to they're targeting weak pathetic men
like this inels yeah I mean yeah this
this guy like he look I'll try and be as
nice as possible if you're willing to
get a hammer and smash the glass on a
painting and then scream in a room of
people without one time Googling what
you are saying you are not a high
functioning individual true he must not
be having an time of meeting ladies
right and so when this woman says why
don't you come with me and do this thing
he says okay now I'm not saying it's
absolutely what happened here I'm just
saying this is a common thing you notice
that politically men tend to skew right
women skew left men are a little uh a
little bit down the middle and in
biology ear muffs for your kids in
biology it's called the sneaky
that is the actual biolog biologist term
for individuals who just try and you
know they they they sneak in to get laid
there there are the strong males who
succeed in courting the women and then
there are the sneaky like
Revenge of the Nerds yeah great that was
that was a dark moment saw that when I
was like 16 that was crazy that movie
was messed up he rapes the woman and
then she's like wow but I liked it yeah
what Revenge the nurse you got to watch
that movie if you never seen it it's
it's like message on accident was that
supposed to be that he was the good guy
yeah like if you do a good job she won't
think it's raped that was the theme of
that so so she C she he's he's in a
costume she thinks it's her boyfriend
and then they do it and she's like wow
that was great he's like ha he takes off
the mask all nerds think about his sex
yeah that's a horrible movie why would I
watch it well the movie is actually
hilarious it was just a really bad call
to do that scene like that dude in like
did you guys see Airplane the movie I
mean it's girls talking about the the
young girl that she likes her coffee
black like her men and she's like nine
or 10 or something like they got away
with that stuff in the 70s and ' 80s no
C there's a movie uh out right now
called uh what is it called totally
killer or something I don't know it's
got It's it's on Amazon and it's um
Kieran shipka and she plays uh te like I
think she's a teenager who goes back in
time to the 80s because there's like a
serial kill in the 80s I you got to
watch it but it's really funny how they
make fun of wokeness cuz all the kids in
the 80s are just like they're just being
kids and doing what they want and she's
like getting offended someone makes a
crude comment and she's like whoa that
or there's a guy wearing a shirt that
says like Federal booty inspector and
she's like that is problematic
and they're like what problem nobody
cares dude everybody's totally fine with
it it would be cool to do skits where we
time travel back to the 80s and then the
whole Cinema is like 80s style C movie
and then back to the 70s and it's like
disco style like we're making a we're
making a '90s room love for the we just
bought uh a '90s sound system '90s man
crazy about the '90s when I think but
the' 9s were the last decade that's why
when you think of the '90s I like the '
80s probic
I I would say I probably like the 80s
more than '90s I think of likeit what
we're building is we've got uh we're
we're going to have a bunch of vinyl uh
it's not really a 90s room but we I have
uh almost every Life Magazine ever from
its Inception I actually have the first
copy of Life magazine it was called
something else before it got bought and
changed but it's really amazing when I
was reading uh a pred D-Day Life
magazine and it was talking about how
the US was stockpiling arms in the UK as
a defensive precaution and then sure
enough like we know it happened uh you
know a couple weeks later mhm the
Americans stormed the beaches of
Normandy at the time they lied and
reported we are helping the UK sharp its
defenses as you know Hitler advances
blah blah blah so it's really
fascinating to read a news article from
when like that's disinformation during
the water Watergate scandal or just a
lack of information or today's
disinformation you could read a story
and it's like this politician said these
things and then later on they'll go
actually said something different which
one's true I got a question for
everybody in the chat too what what year
was the best in the 90s what's your
favorite Year from the 90s Windows 98
was a big deal that was a good system 95
changed the game play Ora on that thing
try to you have to like no I was on on
the Mac I can tell you what my favorite
year the9 on Mac my favorite no I don't
want to spoil it 1993 why it's just so
much changed in 93 technologically like
16bit Graphics Super Nintendo genis when
did that come out 91 or 89 even maybe 90
Genesis I think might might have been 89
actually yeah yeah it was was that
Master System Master System was a little
bit before made a version of it that
used a a compact disc though that would
93 was like CDs started popping in ' 929
well it was a little bit before that 93
CDs were out in the 8S yeah
rollerblading was hot yeah it was a good
year F A lot of people got 90 98 96 97
97 96 are always great Vantage when
you're picking out records but 97 uh 97
96 so I then to record I'm going to pull
it for sure yeah it was like' 91 and '96
were like different realities I got an
idea Super Chat the the N the year of
the 90s that you thought was the was the
best that's a good idea give was
$1,995 right so if you want 1998 to win
that'll be
$1,998 kind of joking almost like oh the
1892 say which year year ever was 33 ad
year of Our Lord before the show started
how the '90s were the last decade and
it's like kind of tongue and cheek but
so much technology changed in 90s and
the internet became so prevalent where
like it wasn't about be there 8:00 to
watch the show and then maybe you'll see
maybe you can tape it on your recorder
it's always on the internet now
everything's always
there it is not tongue and- cheek the
'90s was the last decade what that means
is the the the the the uh the 20s the
tens the 1900s the tens the 20s the 30s
the 40s the 50s the 60s 7s the ' 80s the
' 90s each of those has a distinction to
them for something specific the 9s has a
distinction to it the 000s do not 2010
does not 2020s do not yeah they just
felt like an extension of the ' 90s 2003
still felt like 90 something it's like
from 200 how long do you think it took
for them to to understand that the vibe
of the 80s though like how long after
the 80s did it take before people refer
to that that looks very
98 like really got popular 2012 That 70s
Show came out in the late '90s MH 20
years was that late imagine if they made
a show today called like that 2005 show
you'd be like huh be wearing the same
thing if you go to Hot Topic they're
selling the same products they sold 30
years ago nothing has changed kids are
still buying Nightmare Before Christmas
it hasn't changed if in the 80s they're
wearing uh leopard print hot pink uh uh
you know hot pants and they're
rollerblading around in circles and
they've got mullets and then in the '90s
they all have long hair with with baggy
jeans with ripped knees and flannel
shirts there's a clear distinction the
style of music in the ' 80s was very
like cynthy and the '90s was very Rock
and GR almost like back to 2000s to now
there's no distin music got digitized
homogenized and I wonder if it's cuz
like high fructose corn syrup and
opioids stunted everybody in the9 you
ever gone back watch like a show
produced in the early 2000s so you can
def like if you watch lost some of their
their their choice of attire is very you
can tell it's from a different era what
were you going to say here there well I
was going to say I feel like a lot of it
is the dominance of the internet there's
a lack of creativity and a lack of
community building like parts of the
things that we're referencing with
the80s you know with the ' 80s Neon or
whatever else with the with the hippies
and the 70s you get like the more
pattern the feathered hair whatever else
those were things that people were doing
in their social groups that were more
widely adopted as they spread by the end
of that decade and then it changed and
then now that we have put everyone
online and maybe that's why you feel
like the 2000s sort of the end of this
like you can feel distinction there
because at that point the internet
really took off it became not only
something something everyone had in
their home but in their pocket all right
we're going to go to super chats so if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at
timcast.net off of super chats and I
scroll all the way back up through all
the super chats the year 1999 is the
best whether anyone wanted it to be or
not because that's just like that's just
a generic number you can Super Chat it
was digital Fidelity hit 1080P and since
then the human brain can't comprehend
more I mean it can but it's like that's
it's just become hyperrealistic now and
it's it's never like the office may as
well have been made yesterday it looks
the same I think we see the changes a
lot more gradually too cuz before it was
like every month there was a magazine
that came out but today we're on Tik Tok
every day so like different Trends you
like it's almost like the frog metaphor
where if you warm the water up slowly
you don't feel it well what happens is
there used to be a handful of channels
and a handful of radio stations and it
was a top down broadcast so they don't
want to invest in 800,000 songs they
just want to find the one good song
people like and so everyone hears the
same music if you go into a bar you turn
on Bohemian rap city everyone will sing
it but if you put on any modern music
the singing stops because like three
people might know it and another 27
don't it's all niched out all right
we'll read some more Super chats we got
Derpy dolphin says I heard a fizer ad in
the grocery store today and I'm not
going to read any more of that Super
Chat thank you very
much all right we'll grab some more
there there were a few early ones I know
uh I believe Clint Torres got the first
Super Chat but YouTube appears to have
uh removed your Super Chat and a few
others in the beginning but uh shout out
to Clint Torres for once again saying
howdy people and getting the first Super
Chat of the day he said that he died but
he is back and then the rest I don't
know CU it was
removed all right let's see what do we
have sir rank zero says says hey Tim if
you look at the page dated 2323 you can
see a sentence Bleeding Through the page
that says I'm a queer also the photos
show that there are multiple books
notice the different bindings
interesting interesting so there's
actually several different books and
there's also reportedly a video that's
not been released yeah interesting David
R says Tim I got married on Saturday
please shout out my beautiful wife
Christa watching tonight shout out
Christa congratulations on being married
Christa R and David R congratulations
guys that's awesome
what do we got hopefully he got married
somewhere with foliage because it has
been really beautiful this year Buster
Ruckus says with the way they hid this
Manifesto I'm convinced they are still
hiding something but the Vegas shooter
targeting a conservative Country Concert
perhaps but I believe
um what did they say he was a gambling
at the latest story is that he was a
high stakes Gambler who was angry that
he was being mistreated even though that
he was like high status or whatever I
kind of don't believe that at all
because it was a gun deal went bad right
that's and for some reason they started
shooting and multiple Shooters would be
explained and and uh uh the fully
automatic some people think that it was
government related and that's why
they're not going to kill him and they
wanted to cover up that it was that it
was a gun deal and so they did a mass
shooting so it looked like him as a py
they this guy came in to do a gun deal
and maybe he wasn't even with government
I don't know and then the guys who came
in the deal went sour and they started
shooting and they're unloading who knows
who knows I'm just saying the
explanation that he was like a a high
status player as as someone who is a low
status player at these casinos like I
don't have the elite tier or anything
they still treat you very well like I I
don't I don't you know I don't get it
I've had my problems don't get me wrong
but typically they they make money off
you giving your money away they try
really hard to accommodate you like if
if you go to there you say like I want a
free drink now they'll be like okay okay
fine we'll give you a free drink like
people they roll their eyes at you and
be like whatever most casinos just give
you free drinks they want you drunk
right they want you gambling money in
Vegas and and stuff like that so you'll
spend more time there they want you to
be Happ they pump oxygen in is that what
you said they do they pump oxygen oxygen
extremely comfortable carpeting I mean I
if the argument is he wanted to be given
like the they have secret rooms that all
these casinos people don't know about
but like you kind of know about maybe he
was like I want the Ultra Premium his
brother up too for months later for
something they found on his computer he
had like planes and stuff but uh yeah so
little known fact is that they have
secret gambling rooms and uh you can
look them up and try and find them
because it's not that they're so secret
but they are secret if you are somebody
who's worth like $100 million you want
to hide their identity yeah and you want
to gamble like $500,000 in one night
they're going to bring you to a private
room with private security guards and
they're going to and then you're going
to play with a bunch of other
billionaires and whatever and no one
will know you're even there yeah it's
crazy cool even super cool rooms yeah
they uh uh I know for a fact I think
most people anybody anybody who plays
poker knows this too they have secret
poker rooms where like Hong Kong and
maau billionaires show up and play with
like people for like a $2 million Buy in
it's like it's like James bondes I was
talking to a dealer and he's like yeah
yeah we had uh you know we had a pro I'm
not going to say the Pro's name but a
pro came down with a bunch of Chinese
billionaires and they were playing like
a million dollar buying game like it was
nothing that's just like that's crazy
another reality man so these strata of
humanity existing some people just live
on their yachts and want it all to he
was saying the ultra wealthy uh uh
Chinese like Hong Kong and maau
billionaires didn't care that they were
losing to this poker Pro because wanted
to be playing with the poker Pro they
want to be playing with the poker Pro
they wanted to play poker cuz it was fun
and the million dos meant nothing to
them because they they're worth so much
money they were just like oh I don't
care and the poker Pro who is worth
millions makes his millions by playing
against people who want to play with a
pro it's crazy dude like only fans for
poker players you I got I got to tell
you man that's true the crazy thing
about the world in terms of class and I
say this a lot people people don't like
hearing this is that a lot of the class
distinction is a choice and I'm not
kidding there are people I know who are
very very dumb and come from Humble
upbringing but just started selling
Gucci products you know I I use it
figuratively to ultra wealthy people so
like someone can make a bunch of buy a
bunch of beads and make a necklace and
sit on the street and sell it for a
dollar or you can make five of them find
a big party buy buy a thrift store dress
go in there and say they're $33,000 a
piece and you sell them it's a lot
easier to sell one thing for $1,000 and
a th000 things for $1 I know people who
who make they do one deal a year and
they make 300 Grand and then they don't
work for the year it's all about who you
know yeah and being confident if if you
can convince a rich person to buy
something off you then that's it and I'm
not saying everyone can do that I'm
saying there there are people I know who
are like I don't like working at a cafe
anymore and they went and sought out
like Beverly Hills parties went to bars
met people and got connected right and
then all of a sudden they're just rich
but if you like have this philosophy
that it's all the oppressor versus the
oppressed that it comes with like a
certain hopelessness I feel like that
keeps people from Taking Chances or
doing entrepreneurship things because
they feel like the system will never
render any success for him but I have a
feeling if any of those people made a
couple million they would quickly change
their tune about oppressor versus
oppressed once you get that money man
all right we got some big news here uh
the dude to bid says Hey guys update
update here in Illinois the assault
weapons ban has been upheld by the
seventh circuit it's expected to get
scooped up by scotus and heard next year
PS you should have colan Noir or Mark
Smith from four boxes Diner on we should
uh we yeah coen's been invited he has an
open invite he's a busy guy he's doing
his thing um yes this will be very very
interesting and I also want to stress uh
in Lauren Southern's infringed
documentary Lauren Southern and John Dua
their documentary is coming out tomorrow
on
timcast.net
channel but if you want to watch the
full thing it's going to be a members
only documentary experience at
timcast.net promoting it so let me just
say a few things when you become a
member at
timcast.net
about this issue could you do it and
they say yes then we say now we're going
to take even more money and we're going
to buy massive ads across the across
Facebook and x and YouTube promoting
what we want to win which is the right
to keep in bar arms so I just want you
to consider this when you're watching
the uncensored member show and you're
having a good time that money you give
us isn't just so you can watch the show
and we go buy cheeseburgers with it it's
literally now funding commercials
promoting gun rights so it's not that
we're doing as an activist organization
we're hoping to make money by doing it
but this is the cultural expansion so I
really do appreciate everybody who
becomes a member cuz that's what we're
doing plus we buy Taco Bell anyways buy
Taco Bell you know yeah yeah but um just
understand that the things we invest in
are cultural Victory and I hope that the
large large amounts of money we invest
in marketing this uh the ads in and of
themselves are a cultural victory in
expanding not it's it's not only about
that we're literally promoting the right
to keep in bare arms it's that by
putting money into this what happens is
you get other channels being like wait
wa wait
you you're going to pay me how much to
sponsor a me to to to SP to uh you're
going to sponsor x amount of dollars to
promote gun rights a lot of channels
will then say I will absolutely accept a
gun rights promotion ad if it makes me
money and they may be a apolitical they
may not even care and now you have a
bunch of channels that are like maybe
video games talking about the right to
keep in bare arms and that's how you
reach people in other spaces so we're
doing the work we're doing the work all
right where do we go what is
this alahad says hi Tim I suffer from
paranoid psychosis and sometimes my
anxiety makes life a living hell ssris
are a godsend if not over prescribed
saved my life Fair absolutely absolutely
glad to hear that that's working out for
you and I think it's fair to say yeah I
don't want to demonize everybody who
takes this either we you got people on
the right who don't want to be guns so
they say hey it's the drugs and it's
like how many people are taking the
drugs and how many mass Shooters do you
have it's it's microscopic how many
people own guns how many mass Shooters
you have it's microscopic let's let's
just blame people who are who are unwell
and figure out how we can stop them yeah
and and actually help them before it
gets to that point yeah and I think the
point about ssris is is good because
there are people who benefit from it I'm
not trying to say all modern medicine is
awful just on its face but you know I'm
sure this person could also say that it
wasn't NE it would be unusual to hear
that it was just you you were prescribed
something the first time and it worked
immediately unfortunately there's a lot
of trial and error and that comes with
serious risks uh it's not a perfect
system but hopefully something works
yeah yeah maybe your gut biome maybe
probiotics I'm not a doctor any anything
but a lot of that mental stuff starts in
the gut so uh check out your gut so uh
real quick lot Revolution says Tim the
Chinese billionaires lose because they
launder money through casinos that's
awesome full stop you're incorrect sir
uh when you're playing a private game
where the Buy's a million dollars
they're only losing to each other the
house uh typically it's called a Time
rake at these high level games they're
not my understanding is they're not
taking a rake off the table they're
charging for the time that they're in
the private room so every player who
comes in uh higher Stakes usually it's
like every half an hour you you pay a
certain amount of money and it's
actually the higher you go it does not
go higher it's just these rich guys go
to the casino and say we'll we'll pay
you $20,000 for a private room and a
dealer for three hours and they go okay
then they all play millions of dollars
and they lose it only to each other so
they could be laundering through each
other Fair Point the two Chinese
billionaires could be like oh no I lost
a million dollars to this guy and that's
a way to make a political contribution
or something that's the scary thing
right politicians play poker and
that's the easiest way wow to that's
right you get I was so to have a pool
table in the White House was like
Jackson or somebody the first one that
put a pool table in the White House and
it was like a big story when it happened
gambling was associated with pool tables
politician goes to a casino and plays
let's say uh let's say 1025 buyin $10 25
uh blinds and so we're talking about
tens of thousands of dollars someone
actually thinks they're going to win but
just goes man I fold and then the dealer
shoves 10 grand into that politician's
lap which he can then use for whatever
he wants he's got to pay taxes on it
it's gambling winnings but that's one
way to get large sums of money to
politicians that stuff's got to be got
to be checked out but I think there's
really nothing you can do in that regard
but again Fair Point that's why they
they may be laundering money through
each other but not losing to the casinos
all right let's grab some
more Tyler Adams says Tim have you seen
the final episode of Attack on Titan
from this weekend if so what did you
think I didn't but I I think I read the
Manga a long time ago so I don't know
that's a that's a great show by the way
it's a great story a great story yeah
great animation last name first name
says apparently an older gentleman got
attacked by by a paltin and protest in
LA and died from a head wound on the way
to the hospital olly and Jack posted on
Twitter I did see this we do have some
stories from uh local Jewish outlets and
uh I don't know if we had enough
information to actually report it
tonight but the uh there's photos and
there's video an old man reportedly was
hit in the face by a pro Palestinian
protester with the megaphone fell down
and hit his head and died so I don't
know to what degree we have confirmation
yet because we haven't been tracking the
story as we've been doing the show but I
I recommend fact checking that one I
just got a chat 1998 this is from danne
font 1998 was the greatest year in
gaming history nothing has ever come
close he back it up too yeah Fallout 2
balers gate halflife Resident Evil 2 the
list goes on Z Super station year or
excuse me the
play Dane is correct 95 I think is when
PlayStation came
there's probably way more games too in
'98 resil rude War oh goes on Resident
Evil 2 was re was like a revolution I
remember Ocarina of Time jeez Mario
partyio Mario Party yeah 98 Pokemon
Yellow holding it down yep yellow snap
we have more Super Chatters I don't want
to steal the thanks Dane but uh thief
the Dark Project that was that was
around yeah that's a big deal that game
was speeduns are crazy ground break
yeah what do we got ch Paco Taco says
zinsky is saying irresponsible to hold
elections during war with Russia
democracy still sending the money where
is the story that's right zinsky said we
we can't do elections we can't it's just
now is not the time I'm the president
did you see him say we can't we can't
surrender to this effing terrorist Putin
he he's like speaking in English now
seninsky it was kind of cool they beeped
it say that uh the attempts on his life
have left him scarred and disfigured and
that he would be dissol he would be uh
uh creating the first Ukrainian Empire
oh interesting who said that zinsky yeah
after Wu uh yeah so this is how
democracy
di yeah he was like notably like the the
you we're losing our best humans this is
horrible and we got to stop but we don't
want to surrender we got we got big news
Jason Dixon says Tim please shout out
your Discord we are going to have Scott
Pressler on our after dark show tonight
timcast.net
join us well well well ladies and
gentlemen if you become a member at
timcast.net get access to the Discord
server after our uncensored show WS
Scott presler will be hanging out in the
server with all y'all so that's really
really cool what you guys are working on
that's fantastic great to hear it I love
this Grassroots organizer going super
Grassroots on Discord when he was on the
show they were like come on he was like
I absolutely will it's not surprising to
me that he made it happen so fast so
legit he's so
fun all right what do we got why not
bill says maybe if you finished school
Tim you would be able to read that word
JK school is stupid yeah you know I P
Biden I I accept it methodically I
couldn't read it I want to say
methodologically because I'm always
talking about the uh methodological and
technological advancements in journalism
it's like a thing and so I'm trying to
read this word but my brain is not
pressing methodically me theis on the
wrong sybles exactly yep that exactly
what happened and uh you know we all
have our Biden moments the only problem
is that Biden has them seemingly every
day which would call that's why they
called we call them Biden moments yes
you here's our consecutive all the time
and that's too
much
yes all right true B Benz says the Tim
the problem they have with you you're
not radical either way Common Sense is a
threat to the establishment we all
appreciate you and others keeping
America informed thanks you know I do I
do think this um we're not partisan
enough and so if someone is is is very
directly partisan staunchly conservative
whatever it's very easy for the
establishment to call them an other MH
but it's much much harder when you have
this room when Hassan perer calls Ian a
conservative everybody laughs at him
right like anybody who's looking at Ian
it's like what is he is that green
velvet sure is right it's like this this
not a representation of a conservative
so Hassan struggles to criticize Ian as
an other but Ian has ideas that
contradict the establishment narrative
how do you constrain something like that
it's easy to point to Jack bobic wearing
a suit and be like haha look at that
suit wearing guy he's not like us we're
cool in our leather jackets and then you
get green Ian and they're like he he's
conservative this is inspired by Chase
geyser by the way with his badass Blazer
over there oh thanks I appr I got I got
to man up I got to was right lightning
bolt look at
that right all right we'll grab some
more Super chats Grant AR says did you
finish Attack on Titan if so what are
your thoughts man everybody's asking me
I I thought the I thought the manga was
over a long time ago I'm pretty sure I
read the end you know I don't know I'll
have to I'll have to check it
out let's grab some more what do we have
here X Y and Z says how about this for
an executive order any University that
takes Federal money has to reach into
its own endowments to pay off their past
students debt problem
solved um here's an executive order as
of January 1st 2024 all universities are
hereby
dissolved that's what I'm talking about
what about like Hillsdale though radical
problems require radical solution mayy I
mean there all oh okay even the
privately funded ones they have to
collapse too yes that's right okay
diabetes is illegal and then we send in
uh the National Garden there goes your
insulin prices they should at least stop
calling them universities cuz they
they're they're using the word universe
that's cheap nonpartisan Kitty says
McDouble used to be a $110 now it's
$4.95 I'm assuming that's like in some
Urban markets but man remember the
dollar menu y yeah Wendy's dollar men do
not remember it was actually a dollar
like years just the fries were a dollar
everything I just want to stress
frosties were if you went back to like
1870 and said you were eating off the
menu they'd be like whoa a
dollar we got a Richie boy over here
menu we got Homestead with that the
dollar menu in the 1800s you're like
buying a house it's like literally just
the state of Illinois would you like a
state that's kind of crazy though like
what would you do if you were buying
something they had half pennies back in
the day that's crazy sometimes the penni
is just too much yeah I mean Manhattan
was buffered what $24 and some some
Goods $24 for the entire how much it's
worth now yeah but hold on is that $24
and today's dollars or or they no it was
back then but it's still 24 bucks it's
not that much what was 24 the manatt
island but the the other issue is that
um what people don't understand about
this is that it actually wasn't bought
for anything the Native Americans were
like these crazy guys are giving us
money for no reason and they were like
we just don't want you and they're like
okay we'll go there like 60 gilders
worth of goods that are worth around I
don't know but they they gave it Peter
Manu is that like pallets of stuff from
the West India company purchased it so I
want you to imagine this imagine there a
guy watering a lawn and you walk up to
him and say I'll give you 50 bucks for
this house and he goes okay sure then
you give him the 50 bucks and then he
walks across the street to his house and
goes into his house that he lives in cuz
he doesn't own that property it's not my
dog right that's basically what happened
with the Native Americans on manatt
island they're like if you guys go
across the river we'll give you 20 bucks
they're like deal apparently a Gilder is
translated from Dutch German Gilden
meaning um a gold Penny ah maybe wof
Fett says Tim a McDouble here in Rock
Springs Wyoming is $249 before tax
I still would not recommend eating it at
all yeah start cooking get some red
lentils you you hit them with some oil
get them sizzling and then boil them for
about 15 minutes some salt and vinegar
oh my it's the best base you can make so
much goodness out of that so so uh last
week Monday I was feeling really bad
achy stiff and I'm like man it's like
something's going on you know and so uh
this past weekend I ate pretty well we
went to a nice dinner I had like a soup
I had the it was a really nice
restaurant that had pretzels as an
appetizer and dinner rolls and I'm
thinking it was the bread so Monday I'm
I'm feeling stiff and achy for no reason
I'm like I was like I was rested so I
stopped eating the bread the next day I
went pure keto 100% yeah cuz I was doing
keto for a while and then I eased off it
but I'm still relatively low carb and
then I cut bread out entirely but kept
some starches and I feel like a million
bucks I think the bread I I say this all
the time the bread screwing me up it
cuts down into sugar yeah but I no I
think it's the gluten it breaks it into
sugar your body do I I I've had no
problem with potatoes and I had a nice
dark chocolate with some carbs in it and
uh uh some Maple uh some Maple honey
mustard with beef but no bread and uh
million bucks I really do think it's the
gluten yeah man I don't know but you
know take 10 days off I'm doing like
that that isolation diet stuff that like
the PE have talked about nice you got to
do the Shackleton diet just penguins and
Ice
Penguins but I'm going to so you know
you know the cost of penguins these days
are you crazy I did keto for for like
almost a year and a half two years or
yeah just about and uh felt great mhm
and then I was like now reintroduce a
little bit but keep it low and then
started feeling wonky and I think it was
bread specifically cuz now we went out
to eat and I had like a soup and I had
Russell sprouts and uh like like a small
amount of potatoes no problems I did it
for six months but I lost too much
weight I went down I went from 185 to
147 wow I'm 6'2 yeah that's too much did
you feel I felt great but my doctor
that's a fake height I felt great but my
doctor said actually are 62 though right
so did you do bread we can all say that
under President santz it's funny I just
started eating normal again like an
American and I gained half the weight
back here's the funny thing the 6'2 guy
is so uh uh comfortable with his height
he jokes about how he's actually shorter
cuz he doesn't care whereas the short
guy is nervous and lies as his for 5'11
cuz he's embarrassed about his height if
you're actually 5'11 you just say you're
six feet it's such a fake height it's a
fake height 51 and a half that was mine
for a long time I'm 510 and you know 78
oh nice one yeah you know have you
measured something I can't say five 511
Elizabeth war is one 1024th Native
American she is she's 500 times Barack
Obama's 500 times more white than she is
Native American wow 500 times
cool what the uh what the Costco CEO
actually said we can't say on YouTube
and it's so amazing we will say it as
the first line on the member only show
it's welcome to Costco I love you oh he
said something way more serious than
that funer than that that's one of the
best moments in cinema someone just said
sauna in the chat I did do a sauna today
highly recommend saunas by the
way you know we we got the uh cold
plunge ready to go and I think the hot
tub's working again oh right yeah so I
think we're going to get that cold
plunge up in uh up and ready someone
said that the baptism from the Bible was
just Jesus doing cold plunges on people
that was the funniest comment and I
wonder if it's some TR truth to that all
right Cole Leonard says a steak and guac
bowl at Chipotle with a drink is almost
20 bucks had to switch to chicken and no
guac to save money dude that video where
the woman's like I went to the store and
I couldn't afford to buy meat it's just
like eat the bugs yeah that's what
they're doing no thank you your children
are going to man you guys ever watch V
for Vendetta of course y remember the
scene where she's uh when V takes her to
his underground layer and she's eating
this the toasty and she's like Is that
real butter I haven't had this since I
was a kid that's the future for your
kids if they're lucky like 1984 with the
coffee is that coffee she's going to be
sitting in the room and she's going to
bite into it and go is this real butter
and then he's going to be like it is
real virtual butter and then she's going
to toggle her VR headset and then be
sitting in her pod and she's going to
reach with almost no room to a cockroach
and eat it and go Wow real butter anyway
put her V goggles back on I got a
feeling that the bugs aren't going to be
that bad if they're made like lobsters
they used to call lobsters disgusting
insects and now they're like the most
like if they're prepared right it's just
protein some of them but remember we
tried the cricket bread yeah it was not
good it was like it was like d plus C
minus I think there's a reason we have a
psychological aversion to Insects when
we see them yep no I I I don't
completely agree I think any any uh any
man should eat bugs just so they're
prepared for if they have to eat bugs
right you got to practice I'm just
saying like this I view learning how to
use a firearm similarly to understanding
what bugs you can and can't eat what
leaves you can and can't eat you should
know these things not because the world
is going to end or because you're a prep
or anything it's because maybe one day
you're out on a hike and there's like a
road closure or a flood happens and then
you're with some people and you need to
survive for like 16 hours and you need
to know where take longer than 16 hours
before I start eating bugs though I
might just what I'm saying is sometime
sometimes emergencies happen and how how
prepared are you excuse me for actual
conflict right I'm okay with it being
like in an emergency survival lost in
the ground Canyon for 3 weeks you got to
know what bugs you can eat I I I'd be
down for that I understand that purpose
but it's the uh slowly they'll stop
putting out meat in the grocery store
and instead they'll be putting out your
grasshopper patties and all stuff like I
I'm not ready to commit to that
lifestyle I don't want it to be this
subtle change that people say oh it's an
alternative it's an alternative and all
of a sudden it's the main source of
protein all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you do like it
and go to
timcast.net read that very famous Costco
line which we can't read on YouTube it's
really really great and you also get
access to our Discord server where Scott
presler I'm hearing will be joining
after the uncensored show so you don't
want to miss that so you definitely need
to become a member get in the Discord
server and you can even call in and ask
us questions you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Chase do you want to shout
anything out make sure you visit
infowars.com and infowarsstore.com if
you're feeling achy I highly recommend
the bodies that's all I got for you guys
thanks for watching follow me on Twitter
real Chas geyser and that'll be it cool
it's been so fun having you here I'm
Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net
and if you want to follow me personally
I'm on Instagram at hanac Clair Duppy
and I'm on Twitter at HC bro thank you
guys so much and of course Ian I did a
show with Chase what last week I guess
on infow Wars that was hot what time is
your morning show I am live on infow
Wars from 8:00 a.m. to 11:00 a.m.
Central Time until Owen gets back from
prison so that's 9: to noon EAS 9 to
noon awesome um and I want to encourage
everyone subscribe to gamer Maids on
YouTube where we drop in and play video
games from 500 to 7:00 p.m. Eastern
every Monday through Friday Chris pool
and Sarah Jane killing it uh they played
uh gosh what were they playing earlier
today better together or something like
that it's that game where there's two
player it was pretty sweet so they're
almost to 1 th000 subscribers the
channel gets monetized they take super
chats a lot easier to see your chats
when they're super and also subscribe to
me on YouTube and every social platform
I do interviews every day now 2: p.m. 2:
to 3 p.m. Eastern Standard time I'm
going to be interviewing a nuclear uh
investor in nuclear waste recycling I
interviewed bill opman this morning and
the guests are just going to keep
getting better so subscribe and I'll see
you there and I am surge.com y'all uh
it's been a good show pleasure to meet
you my friend uh and yeah I'm excited
for this after show uh not much else to
say all right we'll see you all over at
timcast.net
I